Oh,
strange
editing this song, all we remixing it and
everything. Video that's about to hit.
What does this bear call it?
What's her name?
I bought a bunch of their shit on
iTunes and all these Austin people were
talking shit about them. Yeah, well they
just say that to them. It's like, like a,
uh, what was that band? That cheesy
band? Uh Oh, nickel bag. Nickel bag.
It was like nickel back to them.
And I'm like, I don't care. This,
this song is Badass.
Ladies and gentlemen,
joining us on the podcast is the Great
Russell Peters from points unknown.
My man's a and soldier.
They're making it happen.
Made it free world.
We are sponsored as always by the
fleshlight. If you go to Joe rogan.net,
you ever fucked one of these
things? Fine. No fill it.
No one's fucked that you don't have
to worry. That's the, uh, the tissue.
There you go. Now you know, patent,
if you ever wondered, now you know,
oh yeah, they're great. I don't
want, you know, it's, it's,
it's very embarrassing when you're done,
but when you're doing it, it's awesome.
The fact that you've done this
word guilt jazz does your fucking,
you've hit the bottom like
you fucked a rubber pussy but,
but it feels great. And if
you go to Joe rogan.net, uh,
and you type in the password is Rogan.
If he clicked the link and type in
the password, Rogan you get 15% off.
So it's cheaper to Pete off.
There you go. Save some taxes.
Kids Save the taxes pitches.
Um,
this is the two year anniversary
for Twitter for me. Brian today,
two years in RC for Twitter.
Really? Years ago I got on Twitter.
I don't know how long I've been on two.
I'm not even good on,
you can imagine being free of it, but I'm
at a restaurant Bro. I have to like put,
keep my shit together.
Don't check the iPhone.
Don't check the iPhone. Yeah, right.
I'm sure it's fascinating and I might
just want to know what's happening. Yeah,
you never know. It could be some
fucking revolt and I ran some shit.
Could be don't going down right now.
Wiki leaks as you speak.
You up on the Wiki
leaks, man. Do you know,
I don't really know what's
happening with the wikileaks.
Is it one of those things that you would
normally pay attention to and you just
avoiding it or are you just not know?
I really just don't know
what's happening railing.
You don't know anything about the story.
I know that this guy don't
leaks some like stuff,
but I don't know what he's leaked.
Have you ever been to
Wikipedia?
I have been to Wikipedia,
so at least you're half there and such.
Don't trust Wikipedia cause you're can,
yeah, I'll try and to anybody's
information. Sure. Right.
Wouldn't it be hilarious if someone
was just sending over some bullshit
documents and you know,
he thought that this was all US military
shit and it was actually just some
fiction and somebody made up to see
how much you can manipulate the press.
That'd be a good spin for
them. It's possible. You
know, look immediately smart.
They was immediately smart.
Yeah.
Well the media that can be calling him
a rapist over and over and over again.
Rape, rape, rape community right there.
CNN. This is the thing he didn't,
they're not even the women
are not even calling it rape.
But Sweden has some of the most
liberal sexual offense laws.
Like they have really crazy laws.
And in Sweden if you like,
if you're like having sex with someone
in the condom breaks and you don't tell
the person, then it can be considered
rape because you ruin. Yeah,
there's a lot of weird shit man.
If you know there's raped by coercion
and there's like instead of pimp game,
which is, you know what you'd call
it in America, have some flavor,
no how to kick it.
So the girl gets confused and fucked you.
What you ordinarily wouldn't in Sweden,
that shit's like a crime.
Like they're making being clever to get
pussy a crime and that is hilarious.
They want weak sauce.
Have you ever seen watered down milk?
Ever seen the pictures in the
Ikea things in Dubai? Yes.
They're all was very dumb looking at
us. So it was a guy lifting would. Yeah.
Do you the last thing you
want as a culture like that,
a non fucking flavorful
culture, you know, anything,
nothing clever comes out of their Abba.
People shouldn't be shame, ashamed of sex.
If you shouldn't be ashamed of sex,
then you know you shouldn't have somebody
fucking crazy laws where people do
dumb shit and fuck. A lot of times when
people fuck, they feel bad afterwards.
You know, they've, I shouldn't have
done that. I have better morals in this.
What's wrong with me? What if my
family knew? Well, tough shit.
You shouldn't be able to cry. Rape,
you know, and a lot of people can,
you can just cry. Rape. You know,
there's a lot of feminists that absolutely
believe that if a woman feels like
after the sex is over,
that somehow or another she was
talked into this or manipulated,
that she should be able to file charges
for rape. It's like buyer's remorse.
It's crazier than buyers.
Rutgers,
it's the most ridiculous shit ever.
Real rape is terrible,
but this is just as bad as real
rape the other way, you know,
cause they're raping the
man. Yeah, you're, you're,
you're raping someone of freedom for
doing something that's natural that you
want it to.
You fucking skank has you dirty bitch.
You know you wanted that deck. They all
want it. They want it. It's natural.
If you're fucking heartbeats and
you're young and your body moves right,
your want some Dick.
All right.
I would get in so much trouble if I
was involved in that country at l.
I'm of course you would. We all
would. Anybody who lives in America,
anybody who lives in a land of where
there's a fucking game going on. Okay.
All right. This is a reason why comedians
become comedians in the first place.
Be Honest. There is a,
there is a vaginal call,
Goddamn game going on and
there's a, there's a, there's
a game going on, you know,
as far as like a human interaction,
you can't flavor down,
watered down the game for
sex. You know, there's a Pr,
the personality game is the
reason why all art comes from,
why do you think biggie smalls
was such a fucking good rapper?
Because he wanted to be the man
so we can get some pussy. Okay?
He wanted to be a pimp.
He wanted to be a player who want to be
a dude at the top of a pile of money.
Why? Because that's how you're going to
get the pussy when you're ugly. Fuck.
It's the best in your face.
The best shit you got bitch.
And if the best shit you've got gets you
locked up for coercion cause you were
paying at two chicks at the same time,
you're going to have a flavor
list fucking country. You crazy.
Cons and Sweden just cause you
make good cheese. Don't get crazy.
That's not the same
country, right? It's social.
In Sweden they hold beer very
well in Sweden. They hold beer,
they can take it and they make cheap
furniture. Oh those Paul Saint Pauli girl.
There's going to get cheap furniture and
strong by the way that does not a dis
against Switzerland was just joking.
Whatever. If you're from Switzerland,
you get all uppity. He didn't know
that. We don't make the cheese, bro.
Come on. These are jokes, man, and make
cheese and chocolate and not jokes.
Just jokes man.
But Sweden's got to lighten the fuck up,
but it's weird that they can fucking
Interpol warning and they're trying to
export,
export this guy back to Sweden from
fucking London for having sex without a
condom. That's ridiculous. It's amazing
though. It's so wait rans parent,
he had sex without a condom and that's
one of the condom broke or some crazy
shit. It's like they're not
revealing all of the details,
but no one is saying that. It's
like he took them, you know,
into an alley and pull their pants down
and punched him in the head and fucked
up.
[inaudible] I heard not even date raped
and they be calling me during the whole
thing is bullshit.
Anyway,
the whole thing was just a stupid
thing that get him for something to,
to do that this because of course it is,
but it's amazing that it's this fucking
transparent because here's the deal.
Okay,
one step removed.
The New York Times has released
all of the shit that he's released,
so what are we going to say now?
Are we going to say that while this stuff
came out and you guys knew it was top
secret so you shouldn't look at it and
since the the journalists did look at it
and then they published it,
shouldn't,
shouldn't in New York Times
now have to go to jail to what?
Who the fuck goes to jail? If this guy
was just someone who ran a site that says,
hey, have you got some, I'm listening.
Which is basically what he did and
people start sending them shit.
That's real journalists journalism. That's
real journalists. That's the real shit.
That's what we're supposed to get these
fucking cunt that are heightened all
this shit and talking to the government.
You're not supposed to talk to the
government. He's supposed to talk to us.
What the fuck did you learn?
Did you learn some crazy shit?
What are they doing over there?
Why are we really there?
What the fuck is what's going on?
Why are all these bees dying?
Here's one of the things that came out.
The EPA knew about this fucking toxic
shit they've been spraying on corn that
kills honeybees and they
let them put it out anyway.
They let them put it out anyway because
they wanted to be able to sell more
fucking corn so they're killing off bees.
And the EPA was aware of this.
We would've never found this out if
it wasn't for wikileaks. Wow. Dude.
Pfizer is bribing people in
Nigeria to stop lawsuits.
There's like these lawsuits against them.
So they're bribing people to go after
like politicians and make them look bad.
There's like these memos and shit. There's
a lot of creepy shit. This is exposing.
So you've been reading a lot of the stuff,
obviously the fuck out.
When I first heard that this guy was
getting arrested for sex without a condom,
I was like, what? What is
in these fucking things?
And you go in these things and it's like
it's not all bad. Islam all terrible.
It's a lot of,
it's a fascinating shit.
Like we're finding out that
other countries like want
us to do some shit about
Iran. Like there's a lot of people go, hey
these mother fuckers, if they get bombs,
we got problems like this.
People in their next door,
neighbors and shit who are Muslim
countries like [inaudible] can you guys,
can you hook this up? Yeah. What's
up? What's going on here? Or are they,
how close are they? What's
going on? You know, there,
I mean there's a lot of good shit that
we're finding out about this stuff.
But the point is that the government,
the only reason they don't want you to
know the secrets and what they're doing
is because they fuck up a lot and they
don't want to be responsible for their
actions and they want to be able to hide
shit and they want to be able to look
up your fucking ass hole,
the microscope,
because it's easy because if I
just want to be able to do it,
I just want to know what
the fucks up your asshole.
And so they want to make it that way so
that their job is simpler and they can't
get fired as easy cause they suck cock.
They're terrible at their fucking job
because almost every politician is
terrible. Why? Because the reason why
they got there in the first place,
because again, all these fucking special
interest groups paying for their multi,
multi, multimillion dollar campaigns.
They're talking about Barack Obama,
Obama's reelection campaign.
$1 billion.
Where's that money coming from?
You mother fucker. That's crazy.
There's no way you should be able to
spend $1 billion to get a job that pays
500,000 and not have everybody go,
what are you doing?
What the fuck are you doing?
Who's giving you this money?
What happens when they give it to you?
Now? What do you have to do for them?
What do you do?
You got to hire them.
You gotta do we gotta do
you gotta Change Laws?
You're going to make it easier
to Trump shit into lakes.
What the fuck is going on?
They all suck and that's why they're
scared of all this information.
They're scared of all this information.
It's not to protect you.
That's nonsense to protect
our citizens overseas.
You don't give a fuck about them when
you're sending them to an an illegal war
zones or illegal war zones where
we shouldn't even be there.
It was based on a fucking lie.
You don't care about them then.
If you don't care about American soldiers,
then you're telling me you care about
them now because secrets are getting out
really. Fuck you. That's not true.
They're worried about the
moon secret getting out. Yeah.
Was there anything like
that in these wiki leaks?
Like I'm not actually going to the moon.
You're not yet. Not yet. But who knows?
Who knows what this guy's got.
This guy's got some fascinating shit.
It seems like most of it that's gotten
out at least to the more public is the
stuff like how
these kings have like they're
sluts and stuff like that.
I haven't heard too much really.
I haven't heard that. Oh yeah.
It's like that's what Saturday night live
made fun of and the TMZs been focusing
on is all like these secret lover
relationships at all these princes and
[inaudible] bars. Shit,
keep alarm part of it
and the pallbearers do give a fuck.
Do you not like the guy from Abu Dhabi,
Prince Talk Moon. The guy who runs,
he runs the Abu Dhabi
submission combat championships,
the world grappling championships and he
also, um, like owns a piece of the UFC.
This guy is like some super insane
amount money millionaire type character,
right? This guy, he's got this, this
thing that they do the UFC, it's at,
it's called Ferrari world.
It's like a Ferrari fucking
like Disneyland with Ferrari
Ferrari theme park with
like this crazy ass roller coaster that
mother fucker could do anything he wants.
You know the like those guys, like when
you get to that level of money, man,
that people would be surprised that you
would find some guys a prince in Saudi
Arabia and he's got some hookers.
He's got some chicks living in his mansion
and he wouldn't even know that it's
still there. Those guys are ballers.
Dude, did you ever hear about that guy?
The Sultan of Brunei? I've
heard about him. Mother fucker.
This mother fucker just goes to the limit.
This is what he does.
He sits around right?
And he watches like Playboy magazine
and it reads Playboy magazine,
watches TV shows and goes, I look
hurt. I like this one right here.
And then he finds out what their agent
is and he gives them insane amounts of
money to come to wherever he is,
you know,
for like Brunei for just hang out
for a couple months, see what's up,
I'll give you a few million bucks.
And so these chicks cannot help it.
They have to go.
And there was one of them
who was a penthouse pad or
something like that and she,
uh, got, yeah. And she got a,
she got caught with a laptop she was
writing while she was over there. And uh,
that's how the whole thing came out.
You know,
that all these chicks who had been
saying they were going over there to do
modeling,
there's so many girls that were modeling
in Brunei and they were really just
going and getting gorilla fuck
by this print and all his boys,
the old assaulted and all his pals,
they had like their own club.
They had so much money.
They have their own club.
They have this gigantic insane
ballroom that's like it did the, the,
the ornate decorations
are like incredible,
like gold guild work.
Let's just the top of the blind and the
hottest bitches in magazines and on TV
shows and they're all
hanging out there dancing,
waiting to him to come out in his gold
underwear and just get his freak on with
whoever the fuck he wants. How am I
going into it? You can't hate that.
You cannot hate that. You cannot hate
that this guy's not doing anything,
that he shouldn't be doing what he's
offering them as a psalm. He's saying,
listen, you know, we don't have
to cop products, prostitution.
I'm gonna hire you to just come hang out.
Just come hang out in a hurry
to party. Eventually you're going to
get horny. You cannot let me fuck you.
You know, I got money son. You know,
Super Mario Brothers is all about an
Italian that just wanting to eat mushrooms
with the princess,
with a princess.
Really Super, Super Mario
brothers. No. Honestly,
I don't think I've ever played
it more than once or twice. Yeah,
I never really got about this Italian
plumber that just wanted eat mushrooms and
with the trends says, but son David kept
on taking the parenthesis away. Daymond,
that's how you pimp these modifiers.
Eat Mushrooms and hanging out with
the printers. Hey, I heard you are,
that'd be bad.
I heard you are a DJ like you know how
to Dj like mixed mixed tables and stuff
like that. You could do anything.
He wants his Russell Peters bed.
That's like a main hobby of yours.
I started doing that in 85 really
now I've always experiment,
play around even and have the iPad app
where you can try to mix and stuff he's
into and beef make scratch my stores,
something like that.
It doesn't work that good but it is.
Is there like a,
is it easier nowadays to try to like
match beats and stuff like that and easier
way? He's written in a
file right in front of you.
You just hit a button now and it just,
man, no, no. You'll have your bpms listed,
right? Wow. Are you
going to do is keep your,
hear your pitch at the same
level and you're good to go.
So do you ever throw parties where
you're just the Dj and you're having this
huge Kyle and end up getting, I have
turntables and every house, so yeah,
I always make sure.
Right.
Do you really like, so you throw
parties at your house and you not even,
I just do it for me.
And then if people are there I'm like,
what do you want to hear?
And then I just started playing
shit when Tommy Lee was doing that.
What was that? That rock star show the
dude was doing, what is that called?
The rock star Supernova or something.
He wanted to have a fight with kid rock.
So this was like they were,
they were really upset at each other.
And so you want him to meet me.
So yeah,
because my friend is one
of his bodyguards. Okay.
And my friend is this fucking gorilla.
Just mountain of a man.
You've met John Rollo, right? So John
Rollo takes me backstage. I meet them.
And this is what a Tommy Lee does at the
end of every show. He's got a DJ set up.
Like he makes his own party and he just,
he like,
he just brings his friends over and he'd
fucking plugs in some turntables and
just starts to starts to mix it up.
Like people who DJ,
like even Michael Bisping the fighter.
He's still djs being djs. Yeah.
I didn't know that. People apparently
people who DJ just fucking love Dj.
I love comedies. My career.
Yeah. Hello. You love Dj.
And more than comedy.
I could sit there and do it all day.
Why not? Amazing. See I want to,
I've always wanted to get addicted to
it cause it seems like something that's
right down my, my, my
lane and explain it. Tell me what it
is. Cause that's shocking coming from,
you know, such a, a successful
comedian and someone who,
who's I love standup but deejaying
is on another level from,
makes me like want to try it.
Exactly.
It's kind of like MMA for you.
You know your job is
comedy but you love MMA.
I look, I, you know what? I love
both. Honestly. I love them both.
I don't have a preference. Like I'm like,
I'm never like when I'm doing the UFC,
I'm always excited to be there. I'm never
like, fuck, I wish I was doing comedy,
you know? But what I'm doing comedy, I'm
never thinking, I wish I was at the UFC.
That's the same with me. Okay, so, so you
just have an equal love for the it is,
but, but you see one of those things
you can do at anytime, anywhere.
You don't need people around you to do it.
You don't need to people to be
totally focused on you either.
Like either do it in the
back requirements, you know,
attention requirements for standup need
people to be focused on you the entire
time and not interacting, not talking to
you. Whereas if you're teaching and man,
everybody could be just doing their
thing. You know, people just what?
You need nobody to talk to you.
Then you don't want people talking
about it because you get in the zone and
you're like,
can you play dancing queen?
And you're like, can you fuck off? You
know, it'd be bad. What would be bad ass?
Here's what be fuck your crossfader here.
I'm going to describe to you guys
the greatest show of all time.
Russell Peters d chain while Joey
Diaz talks on the microphone.
Let's try it. Let's try this little
gizmo out. What is this thing?
It's Dj mixer for the iPhone.
Dj Mixer
to do all this stuff, man. Like yeah, if
you go to youtube and type in my name,
there's like videos of me scratching
with like with Dj Kubert and stuff. Wow.
That's awesome dude. I have a video.
Me and Jazzy Jeff d together too.
Damn. That's sweet. Jazzy Jeff.
That guy is
the uh,
Art Garfunkel.
Oh,
rap music.
Yeah. This doesn't work. Socks
right a little bit. Jazzy Jeff was
paired up with will Smith,
man, I couldn't hate that
more. Yeah, that's terrible.
Don't do that again Brian.
I throw that thing in the garbage.
I'm going to have to hit your iPad with
a hammer. Now I sound like an old man.
These kids, what? They're scratching.
That's me. How, how bad is Jazzy Jeff?
He's pretty wished that he somehow or
another hit that will Smith height.
He's so far off. I mean, in the
DJ world, he's highly, I don't,
I don't mean, I don't mean
in any bad way. I mean this,
these weird must've been
your billion dollar art,
Art Garfunkel and pulse on where
the most fuck his art Garfunkel.
Most djs are introverts. So they, uh,
when you have two people
like that and one person,
they're both involved in a team.
You don't think there's some
weird thing when one guy becomes,
we'll fucking Smith. Well remember George
Michael had that other guy in wham.
Yeah. With that guys just getting steady
cock. That's all he wanted originally.
If you look at that guy,
all that guy wanted was cock all day.
That's what he wanted. And so George
got him close enough to that. It's like,
I'm good, I'm good. I've got a stockpile.
He's not even thinking about money.
I think one of the
coolest things about Dj,
one of my good friends is
that his name is Keith.
He's that main editor for South Park.
And he,
every time they have a party he'd
always djs at their parties and stuff,
but he is just like the point where that's
all he, that's his favorite thing. He,
that's all he wants to do
is deejaying and stuff,
but what's really cool is that him mixing,
like I saw him mixed like golden
girls the other day or something.
Yeah. I like doing crazy
shit like that. Do you? Yeah.
Do you do a lot of do and shops and we'll
see you again now they're called Mash
was back in the day.
We just call them mixing like I took this
record in this record and came up with
this mix. Do you have one mass
or mixed that's your favorite?
Goto from back in the day I used to do a
give it all you got by Afro Rican and I
would mix moments in love with it because
after Regan was like a really fast
song in the moments in love was a slow
song and I would actually have to pitch
down moments and love to get it
on beat. Wow, that's awesome. Wow.
You put last time at the fights and I
hear the Dj there and all they do is sit
there going here for fucking murder.
This guy on the turntables,
sometimes they have djs that uh,
when,
when you go to like the fights
and stuff like that, we'll,
they'll have like 15 seconds of a great
song and just start getting into it.
I've got an immediately
transitions to another song.
Like what are you even doing when he's
trying to get an add motherfucker?
He's trying to get as much music in,
in his one minute that he's got the play.
That's weird though, right?
Well because he's like shit.
Otherwise they could get
anybody to just hit play. Right.
So I want to show you what I can
do in this short amount of time.
He annoying being annoying to a drum beat.
It's more just showing the skills that
they DJ instead of actually playing a
song. And every time I listen to my
God, Oh my God, it's cuts or lays.
I'm Dj Jazzy Jeff is, he's like, he's
like the pimp DJ who's like the best Dj.
That's a tough call.
I think he's horrible.
I would never put DJ in front of his name.
Really?
I want them to get the bag can
take fucking success though. Right?
Can terrible man.
I think it's cock cancer.
This dude that I know that's like
some serious ball or character.
He's like one of the
friends of the Fertittas,
he's like one of those yacht characters,
you know,
just fucking yacht and
around the world and shit.
And he was talking about going to see
Dj ts two at new years that it was the
thing to do. And I was like, well what's
the second best? Those are people,
the people that go to see him and know
nothing about music or DJ this is that
what it is? They just like, this
is what the height thing is.
I should probably say, but we should state
in advance that you don't do ecstasy.
No,
Si true.
These fucking people that do actually
maybe with Tsa is doing is hitting this
frequency that only got two
people who do ecstasy can feel.
Who are you guys just talking about by
the way? Which the project yesto okay.
That's who you wouldn't
even put gigantic Dj. He is.
He makes like super huge famous.
They were telling me,
the guy was telling me that on a shelf
in front of 50,000 people for new years.
It was just insane. New Years. She
couldn't let me tell you what he does.
This is the worst part about it.
Okay. He doesn't do shit live.
It's all prerecorded.
So it's basically you put on your,
it's like you recorded a DVD,
stand up,
a video of you doing stand up and you put
it on your stand in front of it and go
and lip sync. The fucking act. Oh
Wow. That's, and you're not even lip.
You're not even trying to
pretend that you're good at it.
You're just like this like when I get
old and I just want to be so high all day
that I can't think that's,
what am I doing when a prerecord
all my steps in advance,
Ashley Simpson was a world they
just go, go add. That might be one,
a funny show and then people try to hacky
throw you off the fucking things just
play on the ground like you just keep
motoring through. They don't even know.
You have to stop. Hey, stop, stop, stop
the stop the recording to fuck dude.
Have you heard that Dj game
for the x box or a hero? Yeah.
What do you think about that? I've never
played it. I just don't get it right.
I guess it's like a guy
really plays a guitar.
Does he really want to
fucking play guitar? Do you
play video games at all? No.
So you don't,
so you don't feel that that's like real
DJ and even though it's like what he's
doing is just crafting a party. Right.
He's putting together in advance.
He doesn't even have to think
anymore though. It's just like,
so once he gets to the live audience,
he doesn't have to think.
There's a lot of thinking that must
go on to create it right now. No, no.
Gives you really to,
it's fucking like 150 bpms.
This I have never listened to it.
I can pull some of that shit up.
Pulls from rash. Let's, I need to hear it.
I need to know what the fuck I'm
talking to. All of those big name Djs,
people telling me shit about
something like that and I,
I've never heard about it before. I always
feel like, how did this happen, ma'am?
Yep.
Djt yesto t e V.
E. S. T. O. R. E. S. Fuck. Oh,
there's a big sign. I think it
was in Vegas. Oh, about his,
one of his appearances? Yeah.
He's there in ears. Right?
I don't know. I don't know.
Um, you know who else is like that?
Is that [inaudible] Guy? I don't,
I've never heard of him.
He's the guy that produced all that shit
for black eyed peas that I got feeling
shit. Oh really? Yeah, but now he like,
they hire him to Dj parties and there's
a video of him on youtube where his shit
just canceled on him like he's playing in.
The first one is the guys are playing cds,
which is even more horrible to me.
You're a final guns. Yeah. You can't blame
school. Russell Peters, just old school.
I like it. I like that idea
of records and shit. Fuck.
She gotta bring crates and Shit. I
still use Serato, which are the, uh,
software. But I use the turntables with
it because he can control it better. Oh,
okay. So more like real
djs. So you have turntables,
but you don't have records? No, I have
the two records in, that's it to rack.
I have all my records in Canada. Okay.
But I'm not bringing them all back to la.
So when you Dj, you Dj there mp3s are
some, you're cutting up MP three files.
Wow. So you can, there's software,
then there's a machine that lets you
manipulate an MP three the same way you
would manipulate a record,
right. Sort of thing.
And it takes MP three and converts
it to the test to underrate it.
So when you have your hands on the wheels,
the MP three is playing.
You have the same manipulations that
you would as if it was when you touch it
and it'll stop.
If you move your hand slowly,
it'll make the same slow record
noise. Wow. Now there's one that best.
There's one at best buy
that I always look at.
It's like $500 would you recommend
something like that? There's a,
there's a system called itch itch, which
is good. Serrato makes that too. Okay.
Is this Dj ts two that you're
playing? Yeah. Let's hear.
It reminds me of like beyond
the mind's eyes soundtrack. Now,
just thinking about yourself.
Blasted on two hits of ecstasy right now.
This doesn't sound like, yes, Duh. Yeah.
Yeah. This doesn't sound right, Brian.
This sounds like seven k
Swedish fucking pop music.
All right, here's DSF versus
Diablo T. Esto versus, no,
not even a versus, because now they
have have versus, but it's now really,
what does that mean?
Okay,
let her, all those people
are in it. It just walks out.
You know what else snuck up on me, man?
Juggalos Juggalos Smash Ogling on me.
Exactly.
You know,
you don't know what Juggalos I dunno
what juggling exactly to Juggalos are.
The fans of the insane clown
posse I remember are fucking huge.
And it's amazing,
man,
because it's like they call out family
that's like a thing that they yell out in
the crown.
It's like a theme with them.
It's like they like everywhere out there,
there's somebody like you and
they might not be near you,
but you can find these mother fuckers
and if you could figure out how to put
them together and put them all
together in one group, you know,
all of a sudden you've got something.
And that's what happened with
the insane clown posse. These,
these fucking people are lost
from all over the world, man.
And they found the insane clown
posse Zaga launch. No fucking way.
They're huge dude. Remember
when they tried beefing with
m and m back in the day?
Well that didn't work out well,
that didn't work out.
But right now there are gigantic man in
m and m can't leave his fucking house.
Right. You know, there's something
going on with those guys.
Okay, look, look what he's doing. He's
not doing anything. This is hilarious.
Fucking dancing guys got in front of him
in front of a mixing. Yeah. You guys got,
by the way, check out this video. It's
called Siesta versa. Dip. I limbo. Right?
Come on here. He's just
sitting there dancing. You're
playing play like pressing.
Wow. Look at all those. He's not doing a
fucking thing that's not deejaying. No.
Put your hands down and look at
the fucking turntable all. Yeah.
It's like he says hello.
Yeah. You're not doing any say that
fucking record didn't, you didn't do shit.
Yeah. He's so, he's not doing
anything. No. They do this all night.
He's dancing for you.
That the way you want to see some fucking
queer dance like that all night. Yeah.
Well he prepared this shit, man. He
didn't prepare shit. People there, man.
Look at all those people. Something's
going on the pay like right. Okay.
What do we attributed to drug
Tribbey twos at an all time high.
It's not just a man. If you were
there and you just wanted to dance,
that's pretty fucking fun. Yeah, but
that, but it's just him pressing play.
Whoever had a louder [inaudible] nothing.
Nothing is happening is just
enjoying the fuck out of it.
See something is happening.
There's an awesome no being always in
the pudding are easy to trick Brian.
If they act it, enjoy. It is a
trick. Partying. It is a trick.
You're there and you're on ecstasy. You
don't want eight cars drive by. Okay?
You want to be listening
to shit like this.
You don't want to be alone by yourself
in that spot where there's nothing going
on. You hear a dog barking or do you
want this guy to hook up this wild,
crazy fucking light and music show that
is dope as fuck and there's a million
other people, they're just
all sweaty together and
you're all got bottled waters,
right? Everybody has a goddamn good
time. You can't call that nothing, right?
It could call him that. He's not a
good Dj. Kresge lay. My argument for
him is that he's not a DJ. No, he's
not. He's like a radio station Dj.
But what is it?
Because he's making this crazy ass music.
Could everybody fucking diabolical
genius who's mastered this?
He's the carless of soulless people
that have no luck and spines.
Not with his music. It's
more with how he does it. No,
it's the fact that people call him a DJ
and they're like, keep them [inaudible].
I'm like, he has, he's not a d,
so it's like calling an actor a stand up
or a comic comic that just steals other
people's jokes. A comic,
you know? Right. Okay.
Well Eve or an actor that
plays a comic and a move. Yeah.
And then he's such a good comedian. Well,
you hear that all the time about actors.
You know that he's a comedian
office, I guess, or the Canadian,
sort of like a guy who studied a
role to be a comedian. Yeah, man,
we all know who the comedians
are. I mean, everybody liked that.
Isn't that one question that you'll always
ask when you hear about a guy's funny?
Like did he just stand up? Yeah,
that's exactly what I asked. Right?
Like Seth Rogen, the, one
of the first things someone
said to me when I said, God,
that fucking dude is funny. I love
his movies. This guy goes, you know,
used to be stand up like immediately.
Like comics want to tell you that like,
he's like, he's like for real,
he's a real comedian is not.
So that's what bugs you. Yeah. That
he's a fake Dj. This mother fucker.
It's actually making that music.
Then he, here's the thing,
when you get that much
success in that much money,
all you gotta do is everybody's going
to be handing you their fucking demo.
Right? And you go, here's 10 bucks. Oh my
God. Testo bought my song and thank you.
Thank you. Thank you. Now I'll just
compile it onto a disc and yeah,
so he just takes other people's shit and
puts it on. Why not? What's stopping him?
He's actually, I don't know. I mean,
is that really what he does? Or he just
clearly he said Joe Rogan
experience is not support these. Oh,
like me if that's the case.
Yeah.
A Dj battles just called out
for in Dj fight or a fight.
Fight. Both. You don't, while
you're deejaying, you have to fight.
I am so passionate about it. Wow. Where's
this testo fellow from? I don't know.
It looks like the gay
sweet and fucking hero.
The case was over.
We talked about earlier.
That might be the name of a town gay swim.
Now how was I DJ and you're walking,
you're walking around pointing his finger
in your fucking focused and your DJ
that's walking around and clapping.
When did this become entertaining?
It's not even entertain it.
I liked the way he moves.
I wish she never would have showed me
this. This is the most awful thing.
Punch them in the files
that you guys are haters.
I like the way that young
man gyrates his hip.
He said Michael that even knew
about it that much. He's not.
He's doing it like some stiff European
move. It's like John Tesh of Dj.
It's like a Saturday night live sketch.
He's exactly the kind
of guy that would that.
Where's that a hardy and fucking worst
or religion Saturday night live should do
a sketch about a Dj like that.
It's just fucking stands on stage.
Impresses me with that funds.
That should be just as impressive
as watching them do it.
That might be a funny sketch
man. Why is he there? Well,
let's just press play and get out
of their fucking terrible, you know,
dance with us.
You fuck when I know like some of the
best djs in the world like that are my
good friends and to me
and not even just to me,
they really are the most talented
guys you'll ever see on turntables.
You when you get onstage. Okay.
And you know, you start your show.
Do you have a planned out DJ set or do
you just let the shit flow? Like no,
like, like a real comic. You get on
and you do what works for that room.
Just moving around. We can
do that, right? Yeah. And,
and these other little
fucking prepackaged,
it's a performance thing. It's,
yeah, it's kind of like, you know,
it's a tuning in thing.
So you got it with is on what they're
into and then go with them with,
from there.
I mean obviously those people are there
because they want to hear the horse shit
that he's playing. Right,
right. But you know,
he's not really fucking doing anything
but that they couldn't do themselves.
Right.
They could've stayed with your iPhone.
You could probably make those
same songs on your iPhone.
I used to work in factories
and both arguments though.
I used to work in factories and,
and when the machines were going,
it would sound exactly the
same and, and, and, and,
and worked in a printing press.
The fucking same noise, dude. Dude.
Dude, dude. Yeah. After
every time it's due.
It's cutting the paper. Yeah, that could,
it's not good if you're
trying to read something.
Maybe we're too old for this shit.
Maybe. Dude. I say that every day now.
Every day I'm like my father
or something. I'm some, some,
I really am becoming that I am everything
I thought I would never be what
happens and you know, when you have kids
that's, that's exactly how it goes down.
It's like, oh, I get why everybody's
just grumpy and wants to be left alone.
You know? That's what it is.
You naturally just getting old.
You're tired of this nonsense. Like if
you want to hear like really talented Djs,
go to Dj's, spin bad.com do
you just spend bed? Phenomenal.
Starting from scratch.
Dj NSFS podcast.
I've SFS podcast.com I appreciate that.
When I'm, when I'm out or, uh, look,
uh,
you know,
club in Vegas or something like that and
one guy just hits the right songs over
and over and over again. It just gets a
good mood going. I know when to expect it.
Like I know if I go to
Vegas and I go to a club,
I'm going to hear the shit that you
hear on the radio that I don't like,
but everybody's having a good
time, so I don't mind that. Okay.
I know I'm not there for me. I'm there
because you know everybody else's.
How does a DJ get to a point
where he can sell concerts?
That's where does that go down?
I have no clue how that works.
But that girl taught guys pretty popular
and he just mashes up other people.
He's the worst too because he has this
program that he uses when he doesn't even
have to do shit. Do that every
now and then though. Some songs,
like when they're mashed up
it's like, oh, it's different.
But every now and then there's
one song. It's like, wow,
this is better than the original and that
he had the on and on with Biggie. Yeah.
Dude, he's played that start.
You start at the beginning.
Do you ever get a blue eyes mates?
Bedstuy no,
that was Frank Sinatra mixed with biggie.
I was it incredible. What's it called?
What's best and on, on and on. Um, dude,
I heard Frank Sinatra with a
continent don't like them anymore.
You should take picture.
I've read all this shit.
I know shit that's trying to catch
bro. No, the one in here. Oh,
and now in the hallway. Although the
one where he's a Mugshot, mugshot,
just read all this stuff about what
an asshole used to be. I was like wow.
It's Kinda,
I kinda used to think it was kind of
cool to like Frank Sinatra because he was
like one of those cool old guy things.
You know,
he was in the rat pack but then
you read about like his behavior,
like how he used to treat people like
this guy seems like a shithead. Right?
He was a boy. He was kind
of a thug, right? Yeah.
I don't know what the mafia to people
who were shifted was he mobbed up.
I mean I know he was in with the motto.
Was He mob
this one? No. On and
on girl. Talk on and on
girl talk.
Any man that calls himself.
Girl talk likes girls so don't
want to talk about girls,
but you know this is it.
Turn this up.
[inaudible] I think you'll like it
cause sunshine in my life was in the
background. Perfect. Mash up man.
[inaudible] you know what
it is at sunshine in my life
and let be the hidden by
Lisa. Lisa. Oh it is the is. Wow.
Wow. I'd never picked that up
to me is alien. Let's say to us.
You figured that out. Wow.
That's crazy. Where is that?
I can't see it man. Let
the beat him by Lisa. Lisa,
Lisa, Lisa. That's crazy. That
you could see. You can just,
you heard that song before
or did you just picked it up?
I can hear it right away. Wow. She
that you're still real DJ nerds do.
Wow. That's really impressive. Do to me,
this is like a language they don't
understand. They watch. Here you go.
See now at all
like the song, it shifts somewhere in
the middle. I don't like it anymore.
Now there's the house person.
It's the wrong version.
Got Towns the House version.
Try that one in order to
play. There it is. Watch.
You must tune to your base to up.
I've got
no idea what you're talking about.
[inaudible] oh shit.
I don't even here.
There's a break in it coming up.
I'll tell you exactly where
he took it from right here.
This sequence is wow.
The government.
You should work for the fucking CIA,
man.
Three please share it is
holy shit.
Three
let's go back to the other side.
Go to the other side.
[inaudible] I can hear it now.
[inaudible] impressed
him the fuck out of me,
Jean Hours. Ah, it was awesome.
That was some amazing shit, dude.
How did you do that? Has so cool.
I'm a music nerd with this shit too. That
was the coolest fucking thing, man. Wow.
It's like, dude, you just deciphered
some fucking Mayan Hieroglyphs Joe.
And that's why I think we even need to
both by DJ tables and start practicing
going are you used record stores and
trying to find cool mascots and kids.
I don't have any fucking time. And get
them involved. Time you come to La,
you come to my house? Yeah, we will
throw down. It just looks so fun.
I can't get into anything else.
There's not enough time in the
day for all the shit that I enjoy.
Things out that gets you, hurts you and
gets you know, diseases all the time.
Yeah, I'm sick right now. I got
a sick when I was in Montreal.
I haven't been able to train all week.
Instead of watching eight
documentaries a day,
you take two out and take those four
hours and put it towards you don't
understand me. You don't understand me.
I'm not a normal person. I'm an obsessive.
I have issues.
I okay,
I'm managing my issues and my issues is
I can't get into anything. What's that?
Where are you training? Uh, I don't
want to tell people this facade castle.
I mean curves one of
hug because the curve,
take those fat bitches don't
choke the shit out of him. Um,
been sick all week, man. What's that?
Oh Shit. I forgot to turn my phone off.
Your phone's ringing. And Brian, really?
This is like podcast number 750
and look at what kind of gay,
I got mastermind hitting me and one of my,
one of my good friends who was a
phenomenal DJ back in any retired
and he had, he hit me with a text
saying, you're a traditional Dj.
Hard to explain the passion in
that nowadays. No, it's not hard.
You explained it very well. I don't
think it was hard at all. I get,
I totally get what you're saying would
that guy does is a different thing than
when you do,
but what I'm saying is that he's providing
something that all these people enjoy
the fuck up. Yeah. That I'm not mad
at. I'm just mad at Paul with Dj.
It's not even the people that are
like, he's the best Dj. I'm like,
it's not a fucking Dj. How dare someone
called my mom is calling you now.
[inaudible] dare you.
Why is my mom calling you?
My voicemail is not set up,
unfortunately. It's fucking Susman.
Chandra, Shandra, unfortunately
ladies and gentlemen.
So,
mmm.
Have you ever Dj and underwater?
You should do that.
It wasn't a time I electrocuted myself.
It's funny,
my dad just got me one of
these things for Christmas.
He just sends me a box of miscellaneous
things and it's always tools and stuff
and it looks like a pin and it's to
detect if there's any electricity in
something. So like if you want to
know, like you're changing an outlet,
you want to know if there's a
debt or if it's still hot or not.
It goes and I'm like thinking, wow, that's
kinda cool. But then I'm thinking, wait,
I've never ever changed or
needed this ever in my life.
So now I'm just like Harry Potter
walking around the house going,
we don't want to look, dude, I've got a
stud finder or want to hang things up.
Right. And you move it along. And
also know I w I did carpentry,
I worked as a carpenter's assistant
when I was, when I was a kid.
There are a lot of construction labor
or construction sites, you know,
and a lot of it was hammering
nails and shit like that.
But you used to have to tap on things and
listen to the sound of where the studs
were. You ready to try to figure it out?
Then you would go away using your years.
Yeah. And then you're find
healing and then you'd find you'd,
you'd measure off 16 inches
really accurate. By the way, the,
was there ever a need to
go past just knocking? Yes.
Because this thing is dope as fuck the
sick as you make more off of the stud.
Right. But usually, yeah,
you can catch the center of the Stud
now you get the center. I mean, look, I,
I kind of get the idea that what way
we're losing all this, you know, this,
these skills that we used to have but
kind of fucking skills or those, man,
we've got better ways of making
the houses now. Crazy breaks.
Those skills are now moving on
to actual jobs. Like pretty soon,
that person that used to check you in at
Mcdonald's is going to be gone because
it's the newest stuff going to be in
your robot is a stud finder now for sure.
But I can't reason with a robot though.
So you need,
you need human reasoning
involves, yes, you need human.
There's was certainly we're
gonna run out of human jobs.
It's going to be a weird thing. I mean
people worried about jobs going overseas.
You've got to worry about jobs
going to robots, you know,
that's the real fear for a lot of,
they get a lot of dumb Jungian
robots that's going to be terrible.
Indian robots will kick your
house. You know, I used to be,
I used to work for a company that I
was one of the only Americans of uh,
40 employees, all Indian right off
the boat or an airplane, sorry.
You mean none of them?
None of them spoke English.
And my job was to teach
them to be American.
So all they had to do
is just be around me.
And like I would sometimes tell
them to do something here and there,
but mostly I felt it was right after
nine, 11, two. And I was like, wow,
why are all these people
here? I, I don't they,
I think they're Indian by Indians
that didn't speak English.
They're generally of highly educated.
I, they, I mean they did, but very hard.
And with, uh, the biggest problem was, is
that a lot of them didn't wear deodorant.
And unfortunately, unfortunately this
room was like 40 of us in this room.
And I was like [inaudible]
that you dated a chick,
ones that didn't wear deodorant. Oh yeah,
yeah, no. Oh my God, I've done that.
It's terrible. Awful little.
Yeah. Little Esther. But, uh,
[inaudible] is too,
I don't know if anybody's heard of the
way I had to go cause it got so bad
because this room was so packed with so
many employees and it just smelled so
bad. I had to go to like, uh, the, the
president of the company. Like, sir,
may I please speak to you for
a second and be like, Hey,
you know this one guy in general
just really smells really bad.
Like there's a fence. It was
really fun. I know it was, but I,
but I didn't know what to do.
I couldn't work anymore when it was
just smelled like a big bio armpit into
everyday.
It got bad.
And so I finally had to break in and tell
him and I felt so bad and he was very
understanding. And the next day the
guy comes in like a full suit and tie.
Oh here comes and goes. How
do I smell now? And I'm like,
Oh, I'm sorry. You know,
first of all that God,
that guy's an idiot because he went right
to him and told him that you said it.
That guys sucks.
Whether pregnant slide it in is a Wiki.
Leaker the weirdest thing,
the weirdest thing about this company
is I never understood what that we were
actually doing though. Cause like
they, they didn't any of them,
none of them had jobs.
But yet it was like,
I didn't know if we were like
hiding people to like, you know,
distribute Indians throughout
the United States or something.
But I had no idea the name of the
company. You will work software, software,
friends, uh, and or something like that.
And they made weird things like instead
of Ebay it was called like he buy,
you know, and then, but you go to the
website and knock off websites. Yeah,
it was just knock off tons of knockoff
websites with fucking imported slave
labor. There was no like work being
made in every, I need information.
They'd be like Goggle it and like, I was
like, I was no work. There was no Google,
there was no real good luck. I just source
if there was no company to this thing,
it was just like what?
Whoa.
It was like a fake software company
and I was supposed to be like the lead
programmer designer and I like made
one website, interior mail for them,
something software friends or
something like that. Again,
you wonder how many dudes or Bernie Madoff
in it. So I'm like, I know Hoe. Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
I wonder how many people who run
businesses or like Bernie Madoff in it.
I wonder how many people are out there.
Just fucking totally scamming people.
It had to be a scam of some sort.
And it was funny because not too,
wasn't saying terrorism.
It was two months after nine 11 I got
this job or something like that and I,
I the whole time I'm thinking something's
not right here with this United States,
this,
this company right here.
There's something going on here and
some of it's being edited or paranoid,
you know,
like America Go America,
we've got to get these terrorists
and stuff and this seemed like, like,
like the weirdest thing ever told us to
Alex Jones who have some fucking reason
behind it. What state was
this in? Columbus, Ohio.
That'll do it. Henderson road.
Wow. It's still there and actually changed
the name of Scott software friends,
but the home of [inaudible] crazy man.
Hey,
I'm by the way, since we're on it, right.
I think you should punch up
a biggie and Sinatra. Yeah,
I think Joe would really likes,
I think you guys are both like this.
What was the name of the mix
would you say? It was called.
It's like you want to go into
the off garden in the ghetto.
There you go. Try that
one. You might like this.
Oh, that's what I wanted to talk about.
This guy, we were talking about scams.
There was a guy named, uh,
you know what Gambola is the,
the Porsche modification company.
Okay. Have you heard of them before?
Yeah, they're like really famous
because they take like these crazy cars.
A Carrera gt is like a $400,000 car and
they take it and they make this extreme
moms when they make it like they
make the body kit looked different,
put like insane amounts of horsepower
on it. This guy was crazy and he's like,
did the wild shit, the cars,
1000 horsepower, 650 horsepower,
twin turbos and shit.
And apparently it was like ripping
people off left and right. And uh,
he went on a trip and someone picked
him up. It was like a business trip.
Someone picked him up at the
airport and just jacked him.
They just fucking handcuffed him and
shot him in the back of the head.
They made him call his wife and, and
try to get them to uh, send money,
send a million euros and the guy
only spoke English so he made his,
he called his wife in English and he's
talking to his family in English so they
knew something was wrong,
you know,
cause he speaks German so
then the guy just disappears.
Nobody knows where the fuck you went.
Nothing.
No one knows what happened and then
months later they find his bottle was
dangerous to rob rich people cause they're
always a little crazier about their
money. Yeah. It's a
crazy story though, man.
This guy was just trying to
fuck everybody. Just, you know,
just like you had one car and three
people that a paid for it, you know,
it's sold it to three people who's
making it the same card, you know,
was just going to fuck
them. You know, and I pay,
I guess he did it to the wrong dude or
something. Probably some Russian dude.
Crazy man.
People get 90 when it comes to money.
Man, I don't have to tell you that. Right?
Yeah. I mean, I, I've never been money
driven, so I'm kinda happy about that.
That's the best way to things I do. The
things I love to do. That's why I like,
yeah,
you're right.
Laid back dude man. You know, as for,
especially for a guy who's successful
as you are, as far as like, you know,
you're the same with you. Stand up.
Yeah. But there is, it's rare, right?
There's not a lot of us.
Yeah. A lot of people you would think, oh,
that person's going to be a
little douchey buddy. Yeah.
I mean it's the most disappointing
thing when they are right. Yeah.
You're always like, ah, but it's one
of the coolest things when they aren't,
you know, when someone has gone
through some, I was situated,
Saturday was the first time I met Dana.
Oh really? And he was really fucking cool.
He's so down to Earth, man. I thought
he was going to be [inaudible]. No,
not at all, man. I was like,
wow. He didn't like, you know,
just meet me and walk
away was he was engaging.
And it was very cool and I was like, fuck
that. He's in the moment for real. Yeah.
It's a real business, you know? Yeah.
So I can't be running the business side.
I was very pleasantly surprised by him.
My nose is stuffy.
I'm going to have to blow it too much
through the Eritrea lights already, Joe.
I like that
slurry buddy.
Miles give a warm round of applause
for the notorious sorry is God.
See
that was all a dream.
I used to read [inaudible] my ball
that we saw Mr Magic Marlin Mall.
I'll let [inaudible] had the red and
black lumberjack put the hat to match.
We'll number freshman the
hotdog and number four.
The dit would take it this fall,
that woman,
the lime light because the trade
[inaudible] number one,
I used to eat sardines for Canada East.
The broad Lucy be tick to free mass.
The flex love bugs figures can best.
I'm blowing homo special number.
Same Bush.
Not that many dudes
that just had everything
fucking rhyme. Just had that certain
beat that made your head move. Yep.
There's a lot of guys and I
liked their lyrics. It's good.
I see what you're doing. I
like it. Yeah, it's good.
But see the only guy you can take as
acapellas and put it over any beat.
And it sounds like he knew that
beat was playing. Yeah. Yeah.
Amazing.
I like that.
But I am sick of that song.
So do you do shows where you Dj,
do you let me now that you're a
famous comedian, do you ever do that?
Like should know, I have two djs on stage
with me when I'm performing. Oh you do?
Wow. Really? I have DJ Spinn bed and
starting from scratch. That's, that's bad.
And then they uh,
they play on four turntables tables and
one place instrumentals in one place.
Acapella isn't there. Fucking
incredible. And how do you do that?
Do you have them do it before? They do
it before the show as the warm up. Right.
And then I have a comment
come out and then that is bad.
And they play and then they played
the audience out on the way out.
Cause the big venues. Right,
right. That's awesome man.
What is the comedy Cnm
Canada like right now? Is,
is there a lot of come from Toronto?
I'm from Toronto.
I'm excited about April buddy.
Yeah.
It's going to be Craig
common all over the place.
What would you started off in Canada?
Toronto was 89 was that hard to start
off in Canada or in 19 and you don't know
what you know, you have nothing
to compare it to. Right, right.
Or that there's a good scene
in Canada. Right. As far as,
especially Toronto. Right.
Toronto was a real good comedy scene
in Vancouver does as well, right? Yeah.
I think all of Canada,
I mean,
they're always a little gems come out of
all these little pockets of Canada and
we have to work harder
because the audiences are a
little more stiff out there.
Really. They're very loving and they,
and they, and they love you to death,
but you still got to earn their laughs.
Really?
I find that in Canada it's almost
more of a, look, we've paid money.
You better be fucking good.
Wow. Maybe charge it to me
and they stare at, you know,
I'm talking about back in the
club days. That's funny. Yeah.
When you start now out, man, it's a,
when there's a huge difference between
people that come out to see you when they
know who you are. Yeah. And someone
who's just coming to a comedy show,
you get a little leeway then you know
you can do a little jokes that you would
never have done before.
Yeah.
And you know that they liked your
sense of humor too. You know,
like when someone doesn't know your sense
of humor and does know how you think
and then they come to a show and
it's like, you know, when you,
when you first start out,
they're just coming to see,
looks like no one ever goes to a club
that says live music and you know,
your [inaudible] golf, hoping that that's
what you get. You know what I mean?
But with comedy man, you know, there's a
lot of people that come to a comedy show,
they don't know what the
fuck they're getting.
They can get Barry
Manilow or guns and roses.
They don't know what they're getting.
It's true though. It's tricky.
It's the surprise bag of comedy.
Yeah, totally. That's why
when someone, you know, it's
like, like this weird music
on the Internet, you know,
and it's like you got to find what you
like and just there's one, I got this one,
you know it's true.
And then that's,
that becomes a problem in some areas
when one guy has one successful style of
performing and then you see all the people
around them sort of like mimic it and
morph into it like a Dave Attell type
thing like David tell has is so specific
way of talking. So catchy. I love Dave
fucking awesome. He's a great guy.
He made like a billion babies.
Billion clones.
The Mitch Hedberg did that
too, right? Yes. Mitch Hedberg.
Mitch Hedberg came out with this fresh
style and then you hear a lot of guys
sounding like so like it
because it was so fun to do.
I'm cracking the coconut water.
You mother fucker.
Oh c two oh coconut water
sent me a bunch of this shit.
I ain't never heard about us Taco.
I gotta get you some Dank,
so thank you very much. My friends, she
to see two oh coconut waters, the shit.
If you've never had it before. I
become addicted to this stuff. Um,
and people giving me shit about
getting sick, like hit. Yo.
What about your probiotics? Man, I
haven't been sick in three years.
The first time I've been sick,
but coincidentally his,
my fucking conspiracy theory, I slacked
off on the acidophilus. That was my fault.
But what I didn't slack
off on was the Kombucha.
I was drinking a lot of
Kombucha, but gts, Kombucha,
they got kicked off the shelves.
They were in the shelves at whole foods.
They got kicked off because they had
more than one half of 1% alcohol because
the mushroom ferments when it's inside
those things. And if you, you know,
it stays in the crates for too long
or if it doesn't get cold enough,
they think continues to ferment
and it gets stronger and stronger.
So it gets over one half of 1% but
whatever the fuck they did to keep it from
fermenting when it's sitting in the cases,
they watered down the flavor.
It's like really watery.
It's a totally different flavor
and it doesn't feel the same.
It doesn't feel like it has the
same health benefits either.
So I think I'm eating dead Kombucha.
I'm think I'm drinking some funk Shit,
mother fucker. That's why you're sick
now after you've been licking toilet.
Don't lick them, Bro. I don't like them,
but I do sit on them and
I really think twice.
Figure what the fuck it's going to.
You don't even put the paper down.
Just wipe them off.
Wow.
I still have not broken that
level of crazy psychological shit.
Think he'd get home, he'd take a shower.
You're going to be okay? I don't think so.
Hmm.
I always pee on the seat when I leave.
Just piss all over it to leave my mark.
Let them know you were there. Don't
let him know. No, I don't do that.
I always cleaned the seat.
If I piss on it,
don't you know I try to broaden that for
a Fab Multivitamin, Pete, and I'm like,
look, there's only so much
of this multivitamin, peas,
they give you away, man.
When people know you're healthy and they
see your page, they know it's yours.
That fluorescent orange shit splattered
all over the seat. Yeah. Like look at you.
You healthy lazy. Looks like you're
checking and fuck lava lamp when I piss.
Yeah. Someone else paying
on you is not good. Um,
let's just as a general rule,
hmm.
I'm reading people's tweets while I'm
talking to you. That's always a bad move.
Is that cause those
motherfuckers want attention.
That's true.
To start going off on you.
They're saying props for me for calling
out yesto on being a fake ass DJ. Wow.
Well, when you start a fight with
anybody, I've found in this world,
when you start a fight with anybody,
there's always going to be a bunch
of people that want to join in.
It doesn't matter.
Even if you're right,
it's like there's always a sa you
could be totally wrong and there's no,
he's going to be like,
I got a million fucking people.
You know that that were mad at me for
the whole Carlsmith see a thing that
didn't see it for the way I saw it.
And there's always going to be
people who are idiots. You know,
there's always going to be
people who don't agree with you,
but there's always also going to be
people that just want to fight about shit.
So if you know, if you're going
after d JTS still, they'll look.
You have fuck them.
I hope fucking carful of AIDS
runs into them like people.
People just will start
getting angry, man, if you,
if you fucking hate somebody to get mad,
they're like too,
I got duped into liking him. So fuck you.
And they're like bond with you, dude.
Thank God you fucking said that.
That guy could suck a fucking
million ranted decks. Whoa, Bro.
I don't think it's d. Jts so that's the
problem. I think we need to sit down.
You need to find out where your anger is
coming from. I need to get a group hug.
So check this out.
You know,
you heard about Miley Cyrus doing Salvia
and everything like that right? Now,
imagine, uh, this something
happened to me with you recently.
I realized how easy this is. So this is
a tip. If you have an iPhone. All right,
everyone, tip iPhone. Um,
if you have an iPhone and you plug it
into somebody's laptop to charge it,
and if it's not locked,
meaning like if you're using it,
checking your text messages while
you're charging on somebody's laptop,
they open I photo.
They can take all your photos,
all your videos off your computer.
I know off your computer
without you even knowing it.
And so that is a perfect
example. Like Miley Cyrus, oh,
my friend took a photo or a video,
you know,
I'm going to use your laptop to charge
Bam. You got all of Miley Cyrus's videos,
Salvia.
So that's a tip.
If you're ever plugging in your
iPod or iPhone into a laptop,
just make sure you're checking them.
They're still plugging in your
phone that way to charge it.
And you're a fucking retard. You're
at somebody's house like, Hey,
do you have a charger? Oh, you can plug
it into my laptop. You know, I mean,
that does charge it up. Right. Does
it charge it up as fast though?
He's a USB port.
Just
missed some calls. Right. Wow.
In the car that's confident in old school.
I don't need this. Yeah, I
can put this down. Do you,
do you ever get the sense if you leave
your phone at home, you ever do that?
And I got a little freaked
out. Yeah. What's up with that?
I have nothing to hide in that
phone, but I get freaked out. Yeah.
I don't want people answering
my God damn calls. Absolutely.
I don't want to be disconnected either.
That's true.
I will turn around and go home.
Yeah. Most of the time. Less I,
if I'm on my way out the door to a flight
and I was halfway to the airport and I
knew I would miss the flight. If I turned
around, I might have to turn around.
Well, if I'm leaving town, fucking
I missing, what am I going to do?
I'm going to fucking not have my phone.
I'm going to be in Cincinnati, no phone,
no fuck.
And then I go wait for somebody to Fedex
it to me or I'm going to go to seven 11
and buy some phone there. You don't
know anybody's phone numbers anymore.
I don't know anybody's phone numbers.
Well you do have,
you have a mobile me service then you
just go online and any have your contact
phone. Yeah. Well that is a
lot of one. You probably have
an iPhone by now. No, no.
What are you on?
Well I use a blackberry from a main
phone cause I liked the whole software
better. I like, it's not as good
for sure. It gets stuck sometimes.
Sometimes we're, it gets
weirded out. Sometimes it rock
shows up. Yeah, I have one.
Sometimes the reboots out of nowhere.
But when you're using it,
but when you're using it like,
like what to answer emails or to
answer phone calls or to forward texts.
Sort of doing anything for twittering
to, yeah. I don't like it for twittering.
I like iPhone is better. I
think, what would I like?
Iphone four I think it's a great internet
device, but the phone is dog shit.
The phone, like service in, in, in uh,
America with 18 t is so fucking Dante's
horrible. There's one can't do it.
So I need Verizon and I need a phone
that's going to work when I'm on the road
and I'm in other countries too.
So January I found most likely and
then hopefully send them. Yeah.
And pretty soon I don't think
blackberries going to last much longer.
I think they're just going to become
an APP on an iPhone saying, yeah,
you're going to have your blackberry
app so you can get used to the way that
blackberry operating system.
You don't see your, sorry,
lasting long apple friendly.
I mean I'm talking about
android and fucking iPhones
that that shit's destroying
all the other guys. Look at
pom poms. Thank you Riley.
And I think blackberries still is a
black percentage of the market. Yeah,
blackberry owns the business
world. Yeah. Until it's a windows.
He would think that it would die off, but
it never will. When you see the first,
when you first got into Mac and I'm
like, my God, this is so much better.
Why would anybody have
viruses and registry hacks
and bullshit and fucking the
pop up windows that eat
all your computer up,
but you know from using the blackberry
how fucking annoying. So I no,
no, it's a new, first of all,
the new operating system.
You haven't used it in a long time.
I used the new one. What's her face?
Is this the torch? The torch? I haven't
used the tour. What's that for it,
but I have a new curve.
The one with the flat track pad
there has never a ball has attracted.
I like it man. I like torches like
an iPhone and a blackberry combined,
so it's like the touch. It's all
touch screen. Like if I just had it,
it's got one device. I might have to
order the iPhone if I on one device.
Bell Mobility in Canada gave it to me.
If I could only have Canadian,
that's why I don't know what this,
if I had to use that as actually now
that you don't know about the torch,
that's the new one. No, I don't. Yeah.
The last thing I saw that was a
touch screen was the storm too,
which was a piece of shit.
Yeah, that was a piece of shit.
If I had to use only one phone,
I would pick the iPhone.
But to use two is better because this
way you don't eat up your battery on your
main phone cause I like to fuck around
with the eyes. Morphe packs, man.
Those are gross. Someone that's carry
some extra ass battery. Some girl,
I had had it the other day,
I saw
it and I played with it. It's not bad.
You'd get used to it. Sure. It sucks.
Giant brick that stuck on the mat as
bad as it used to be on the new iPhone.
The iPhone four piggyback battery.
Yeah.
Well it's kind of built into the
case so it looks [inaudible].
No, it's this one's more features and
going back to the old days when you had a
suitcase for a fucking cell phone
that's we're going to go back to,
we're going to go back to you.
You're going to need so much power to
do what you need your cell phone to do
because of cell phones. Processors are
going to so far exceed battery life.
You're going to be walking
around with like a suitcase nuke,
like a fucking a giant ass battery
that's like a car battery on a handle.
It's going to be attached to your phone
and your phone's going to be able to
time travel. That's what's
going to happen. Russell and
my assistant has the evo.
Oh yeah. That giant fucking
phone. Super battery killer.
Oh my God. We've been making fun of him
for that one forever. Beard, Huh? Yeah.
It looks like you're, uh,
you're, you're my Mac Imac,
but it's cool if you want to watch a
movie on your phone. Yeah. But yeah,
as a battery, the battery so horrible
that he has this giant fucking battery.
It looks like he's walking
around with this thing. Yeah,
that's what I'm talking about.
That's what we're going to go into
the retard gallery. That's actually,
it's connected to the wall and it sends
a wireless signal out to your phone and
keeps it charged.
I think projectors are going to become
a lot bigger in the future where they're
going to be so bright and powerful coming
from your little phone that you could
actually just make your
own screen anywhere.
So we're going to have like a razor
phone with like the Xbox connect style
projection,
wherever you want to
see Olivia,
Nikola Tesla.
If they had just listened to him and
just let him let him work his magic,
we would all have wireless electricity
now and then we wouldn't have any of
these battery issues. There'd be
electricity in the air. Oh yeah, I know,
but talk nuts.
You've seen that new application that
was just released called something like,
what was it called,
Joe?
The seaward applications words C or
something like that where you just point
your word.
I'll check it out.
You point your phone at any like say like
you're overseas and there's like some
writing on the wall that you can't
understand it in a different language.
Just point your phone at it
and it looks like a camera,
but it translates it and puts it
into whatever you're looking at.
It's almost like urban spoon. Yeah. What
did you just point your phone? Oh yeah.
Direction. And it tells you where a
restaurant is, right? Right, exactly.
Just this instant translates
anything. That's pretty cool. Yeah.
It detects the translation and change it
clear. It is. It's called a word Lens.
Word Lens. Really Pretty
fucking crazy. It's a,
you look at it like through the camera
and the camera reads it and translates it
on the screen. It's ridiculous. It's a
free APP. No, I think it's like, yeah,
it's free as a free native
language packs that costs like,
like if you wanted a different language,
it's like five bucks or so.
That makes sense. That's
smart. By the way, by the way,
if you are playing video games
on your iPad or iPhone right now,
he a has all their games for 99 cents
so a lot of these games are like $12 for
your iPad or iPhone or 99 cents right now.
So really for how long?
Till through Christmas. And they have
like sin city deluxe in like Madden,
which is like $13 usually on the iPad.
It's 99 cents. Right. So jump on it.
So what, what is this like a promotion?
Yeah. Yay. Yay. Christmas sale. So wow.
So a lot of these games,
if I'm mad download like five games last
night and it costs me $5 and they would
normally cost me like 50 or something.
What does a game cost?
Like if you go to bio or call
of duty or something like that,
what are they called for? Like
Xbox and stuff. It's like uh,
anywhere from four 59 to 69 new.
Are you shitting me? Yeah. God,
they used to be what? Like 39. So yeah.
But I'm thinking about back in the day
when I was a kid and fucking Atari Games,
I never was really an Atari kid. I
never had it, but I remember them. Yeah.
My parents bought me,
the bootleg system was called the Cam on
one from Sears and fucking Atari game.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Even back then,
like what? Like how many people,
like you talk about
teams that people get on,
how many people were like Sony playstation
or Xbox three and they'll like argue
back and forth and a police station
soaks and it's fucking, well,
back in the day I was a tare versus
colecovision. Yeah. Ended up versus Sega.
There has to be a competition
or it would suck. It's not just,
it has to be competition.
It says everyone has to pick a fucking
side and stick with it, you know? Yeah.
Nobody can go, this is better on yours,
but this is better on mine. Yeah.
Nobody's like that reasonable.
No.
Everybody wants to be with the right cell
phone carrier to you ever noticed that?
You know, if like you have Verizon
rights, fucking Verizon's a shit, right?
All these idiots out there in 18 to,
what the fuck are you doing?
Like they're like, want to join you
in on some fucking Verizon clan?
You like sprint. Are you
with sprint? Sprint's good.
We're sprint were sprint bros creates
cricket. You're going to get cricket.
You're going to lie. There was a bunch
of those little companies, right.
You know what bugs me the
most? Those metro pcs bucking
commercials. Oh yeah, yeah.
The commercial racist commercials in
the history of prices. Commercials.
You know what the fuck man. Somebody,
if I ever meet those Indian boys,
I'm slapping them in their face
trying to wake him up. Wake him up.
What the fuck are you doing to,
they sold us a commercial play it
or you've never seen the metro pcs?
I haven't seen it, but I think
people should know metro pieces.
There are hard here. They are horrible
people in Canada. Don't know them.
I don't think mobile
ones are brutal to you.
Remember the boost mobile ones were
dudes would be like, where are you at?
Oh yeah, yeah. That was the question.
Let me give you the down low on the no,
whoa,
sweet. Totally money. ECS is
offering unlimited talk text in bed.
Just trying to be crazy.
If this can be through Chad maybe.
Okay. But this is obviously on pure
common, unlimited nationwide to authors.
There's like a couple of them that are
okay little. This drives you nuts. Yeah.
But,
but if you made those characters on stage,
it wouldn't drive anybody nuts
because they're saying it's a parody.
They're not actually used to sell
any. This is like one time, it's fine.
You know what I mean? Like I understand
that they're selling something,
but there's selling something with comedy,
right.
They're trying to be funny there.
That's, that's not, it's such a poor,
it bothers me. Get that.
And the fact that like,
these guys don't ever win the, uh, like
I'm always about the underdog. This,
so those would be the
underdogs in the commercial.
I think it would be funnier if they
won. Like whatever it is, they're,
the joke is, you know, okay, I
see what you're saying. So they,
they end up being the brunt and then they
end up being the fucking brunt again.
And they keep on being the
brand over and over and over.
Like when they have like
this big fat chicken,
one of the other commercials
to show 90% coverage.
This guy's looking at her like,
Ooh. And I'm like, seriously, dude,
are you fucking kidding me? I see what
you're saying. I see what you're saying,
that it's not clever and it's kind of
mean spirited. Yeah. It's just like, Huh,
look what we've done. Yeah. How
obvious. Right? Yeah. Yeah, that's true.
My cell phone calls,
keep dropping if you had handy is
into it and you will find a problem.
A sneaked out among all of these glimpses.
Snake like an ice lollies.
I just laughed.
I assume you're on the
[inaudible] network.
Get Metro pcs and you'll be talking smack
on three g but nationwide coverage in
over 11,000 cities and towns $40
I'm sorry man. Let Shit's funny.
I don't give a fuck what you say, but you
know it's not funny. It's the value yet
metro pcs is giving us too.
We just had that nonsequitor with the
fucking snake charmer. That made me laugh,
man. Well, there you go. It's
fart jokes for Indian people soon.
It's not brilliant because they're
just trying to sell some bullshit.
I think they just made them
look so fucking stereotypical.
What would you do though differently?
How would you make it different if you,
if you had that scenario,
give them the Mexican accents.
Okay.
I would've picked really area looking
people and then giving them an idea.
You can always make it
Nazi's. There's no one
around to stand up for Nazis.
Nazis will be on the shit list for a
hundred years until the next group of
fucking psychopaths comes
along. You know, it's like,
I bet for the longest time Nazi
jokes were Roman jokes. You know,
I'd be shitting on the Romans. Right. But
you try a Roman joke today and nobody,
you know, what? Are you a fucking Roman?
Yeah. No. Like what are you saying?
There's nothing, but you hit
them with, what are you a
fucking Nazi? It's like, oh,
that shit's still valid. That's a
good one. You zinged me. You know,
I mentioned one time
they used to say that.
What are you a fucking Roman kind
of Roman are you? What do you have?
That was actually an insult from
the movie. The Hustler, the movie,
the Hustler Piper. Laurie says to
a Bert, fuck, what is his name?
The very famous actor
that died a long time.
The hustler that Paul wasn't Paul Newman,
but it was, uh, the guy who played birth,
fuck, I can't remember his name.
Anyway, she goes, y'all realm, but
it's maybe in the 70s, Nazi. He
was in the, as it was in the 60s,
so it was 1963. I believe that
all of that movie, you know,
60 or 63. I don't remember. I should,
I should look it up so
I don't give anybody any
misinformation and I should look
it up just cause I should need
to know the name of the, uh,
the dude was an amazing actor.
It was it.
So somebody like, can you guys talk
about something worthwhile? Wikileaks,
perhaps you missed it already.
Stupid know about you. Twats
I like, I like, I read the trade,
the twitters now because people
are like sound looking into it.
Like we're going to be the fucking reason
that there's a change in the world.
George, see Scott, ah, George T.
Scott Patton and she and
he played pattern, right?
Yes. Yes. Piper. Laurie
says he already Roman Burt.
You know it's her way of saying
you're a Nazi, like you piece of shit.
He was pimping her.
I think he bone or two as well.
It's pretty disappointing with these
early reviews of Ciaran. Oh man,
no one's gonna see it tonight.
And somebody made a great point though.
It's like if Disney was going to
have a rave, would you go to it?
What'd you think? It was good. I would
go to it. Hi Izzy. Right. But Jesus,
if Disney Henry. Oh, come on man.
Ray would be fun. Even if you were,
if it was a Disney rate, it'll be
fun. I don't know. Disney rave.
If you were super baked it.
One thing to note though is I don't think
I was a huge fan of tron growing up.
I think I was fan of the video game.
I don't think I'd like the movie was,
I didn't know what the video game did.
You didn't,
you can just like the way it looked.
Yeah. I'd go into the arcade,
look at the game, and I go,
cool. Yeah, the fuck does it do.
How do you play this game?
And that's kind of like the movie
kind of was a trick back then.
It was like computers were mysterious
and weird and that's why I think I
remember like that movie. But if you
really try to watch that movie, it's suck.
Yeah. I ever wanted to see
trial. I'm not a shy guy,
so I never wanted to see tron now or then.
Altered states is one of
the most influential movies
on my life because of the
fact that it got me in a sensory
deprivation tanks and I started, you know,
tripping in those things. But I tried
watching it a few years back. Right.
It's terrible.
Yeah.
I remember the commercial for that.
It was the guy with the movie
things on them. Yeah. Well he's uh,
he was looking at the,
what happened
was he went to like Peru or South America
or something. He takes this Iowasca,
he drinks it and then he gets in his
isolation tank and he starts tripping and
having these fucking incredible
experiences and it starts
turning them back into
a cave man, turning them back
into some wild monkey man.
And he wants up, you know,
running around killing people.
It looks so stupid. Oh my God.
It's like unbearably thumb. You know,
you just, you just forget, you know,
you forget.
Yeah.
Or the also like he start realizing
special effects and and dom were a lot
smarter now back then. It's
still the total evidence of
evolution really. I mean,
no one wants to think about it that
way, but it, it, it shows there's,
there's an ethic.
The ethic in the world is things
become evermore complicated always.
And if you look at old television
shows or old music, that stuff is bunk.
You know, old comedy, it doesn't
work. You know, old comedy is broken.
Go back and listen to some old comedy.
It very rarely do you laugh.
You appreciate the craft. You
appreciate. Well in this time period,
this was material and this was,
you know,
it was amazing what this guy is
saying and wow, listen to them.
They're really enjoying it. I get it,
but it's not going to get you. Yeah.
That's why out of all
the old old stand up,
maybe like three albums will
stand up still prior. Still does.
But you know it doesn't like
it did when I was a kid.
Delirious still holds up
real well does it? Yeah.
I watched it again recently
and I was like, fuck me,
this shit is still laugh out loud. Funny.
That was a powerful performance ground.
Someone Carlin's old stuff
still makes me laugh.
Some kinisons old stuff's still
makes me laugh too. It's a,
but that's only 80 years you go back.
I mean in 1980 rather go back
like 1950 go back to that stuff.
Well Marx Brothers makes me
laugh. Still really does. Yeah.
Groucho still makes me laugh. Oh
Groucho was brilliant guy. Man.
Always had some funny shit when
he used to do you bet your life.
It was a talk show game show.
Some guy,
you know had like 10 kids or something
like that and he goes, he goes, Whoa,
10 kids. And the guy goes, yeah, I love
my wife. He goes, I love my cigar too,
but I take it out of my
mouth every now and then.
He did always come up
with those kinds of lines.
It Bill Maher actually kind of hack that.
He did something about loving his bong,
but I'd taken out of my mouth every now
and now when he was talking about the
people who are the, uh, the, the families
that have joking kids tribute. Yeah. Yeah.
Attribute. You would say that. Yeah.
He would say that it was a tribute.
You shouldn't, everybody knows that
line that maybe it is a tribute,
but it's still like, or maybe just
someone wrote it for him, but you know,
Groucho Marx was a,
a guy like that was like to say that
back then he was sharp than his,
his sharpness still
holds up. Yeah. That's,
that's like some 2010 standup
shit. You know? I mean,
this is just to say that Bill Maher has
said that, you know, look, it works.
It works. Now, you know,
there's not a lot of jokes that work
now that would work back then. You know,
I wonder how, how, how much
business like trench coats sales have
gone down since the invention of the
Webcam.
[inaudible] no,
kids are getting better.
Thrill though is to see it's not the
real thrill isn't, you know those,
what is that called? Chat Chat
Roulette where you just, you know,
stand in front of a Webcam hoping
someone looks at your Dick. All right.
The real thrill is being right in front
of them and pulling your dick out and
like jerking off on them most if though,
is it that or you could do it to like
a hundred people at once. Like man,
I'm doing a hundred like I'm,
I'm really down to earth science.
It's just more accurate this way.
I guess that would work,
but I don't even have to run away.
Right. To potentially take a sidestep.
What level of perversity he was
here and then he sidestepped
yeah,
you don't have to do much to get away.
Just pull your head out of the Webcam.
That's right.
But then who do you throw your piss
on or you're here. Come on. Yeah,
that's a problem.
You just have like this big wall of like
a picture of a woman that you to trick
yourself.
You
take, you take, you take a picture
of your screen, put it on the wall.
For a lot of dudes that's
like what they really liked.
You take a picture of your screen,
you take us
screenshot, take a
screenshot, print it out.
Once you're jerking off and as
you're about to cum, you grab it.
Fuckers.
That's hilarious. You have to, how much
do you, just enough for a hundred people.
Who was the guy that got busted? Oh,
it was Christie Brinkley's husband.
He was in debate and Billy Joel.
No, no, no, no. The Guy who uh,
took over on that guy, there was more
than one guy. There was a few guys,
there was one guy who was a,
uh,
a guy that she got in a helicopter crash
with. Oh yeah, that guy died or by,
oh hey. They both survived.
No, they both survived.
But because of the fact that
it got through this thing,
then they had this like crazy romance.
It really didn't make any sense.
And then wound up, the guy was
a loser and she got rid of him.
But then there was another
guy afterwards who was, uh,
it was a crazy beat off guy and he
would spend thousands every month just
fucking whacking off online.
Just joined every fucking
thing that you can join.
It was it 25 a month and I just beat off
on people and they had like video this
guy and it was,
there was an interview.
It was a fucking fascinating interview
where they're bringing up whether or not
he had masturbated in front of a Webcam.
There's been allegations,
have you mastered this?
And he was like,
there was this one time he admits to
tried the Abby tried to play it off this
one time and it was a
completely consensual thing
and it was not that he's just
getting on the webcams consensual, don't
you just have to look away like, well,
it's literally unconsensual that you get
the initial image in the first place.
I mean,
if someone,
if you're just having a little iPhone
chat with somebody a little facetime,
they pull their deck and start beating
off. Yeah, man, you should ask me first.
That's fucking hot, man. Not Man. I think
just the shock they loan is worth it.
Like, well Joe, why are you
wiping out your tick, Joe?
What are you getting so mad at
worth it to you? You got one too.
That would be better.
You know how uncomfortable that be?
If Brian and my pull out my
Dick and start masturbating,
that would be more uncomfortable than
you. Just like, hey look Brian, about, oh,
come on and be like, please don't,
don't do that. Why are you doing that?
Why do don't do it? No, don't
do too much buildup, you know?
That makes it worse. Come on,
don't, don't come. Come on.
I have had friends that have told me, come
off. You know, if you touch your focus.
I had a friend that told me crazy story
about his friend getting a hooker and he
stayed in the room and beat off all his
friend. Fuck the hooker. I'm like, Yo,
I'm not willing to go that far.
I am not willing to go that far.
You're gonna beat off in the room
with your friend having sex. Oh yeah.
What?
That's the same people that,
that didn't care in the
locker rooms in high school.
They were just walking around with their
Dick Everywhere. Same people either die.
I was hiding in the bathroom,
shower.
I don't think I started not caring
until I was in my twenties yeah.
Lean your 20s you're like, you want
to look at my, you fucking Weirdo.
Go ahead. Yeah. But when you're, you know,
I did go to hedonism and get naked though.
Really?
What's hedonism in Jamaica in
Jamaica just went around naked. Yeah.
There was the prude side in the nude side
and everybody was having way more fun
on the nude side. Wow. And then they
were like, come on over. And I go,
I go over in my town. No one's got a
fucking iPhone on them. Oh No, this is,
you know, like a five, six years
ago. Do they still do it now? Yeah.
I'm going to make sure that
camera's there though. Really?
But nowadays you can get fucking
spy cams and crazy. Right.
There's all sorts of shit. He can get
hats that have video cameras on them.
It's pretty nutty. What they can
do now there's the glasses member,
Stan [inaudible],
Stan Opeb,
that show he was doing for Fox was a
hidden camera show and he had glasses that
were like a little camera on them.
There's a button you can buy.
It looks like a shirt. Yeah,
that's all my video camera.
I'm always checking up on like,
like just recently,
the guy that's small enough HD
that goes into a button I saw. Yup.
Shit about getting a couple of those.
You know when you're going to need it.
You never know. Just stayed at the right
girls. Get the right button, cameras
hang your shirt the right way.
It's eventually wearing your shirt.
It's I'm cold. Weird
button. Nothing. Yeah,
your buttons white and that one's black.
Here's a question that wasn't glass.
The bigger button. I have a question
for you gentlemen. When you have sex,
do you guys make a lot of noises?
Like do you, are you loud? Yes.
You will still make some noise.
Really? Yeah man. If I can,
cause I'm not, I'm very quiet, very quiet.
And it's not like I'm not like sad man.
I don't know why.
But now I'm being told that I need to be
louder. Oh, I like how old are you, Brad?
36 you're told.
Now listen man,
we're not within the last year or so.
Lately.
Lately people have been telling me,
let me give you some more very,
very strong advice. Fake it and
just be, we'll switch you up to do,
if a girl ever gets to a point where
she's saying you need to make some noise.
All right, this is what you need
to do. You need to make some noise.
Cause if you don't, she's going to
find someone who makes noise. Right?
So do you understand that? I know, but
when I make, then I make the noise and I,
I to think I about it. I know, but it's
like, it's not me and my personality.
So when I go, you take that can, you know,
I think that's a shyness because it took
me a long time to come out of my show
with that stuff too. So yeah. Listen,
dude tried choking myself and
masturbating everything. No, I know.
I got to learn how to take the potion.
How are you going to catch the combined?
If you don't learn how to take the pussy,
there's, there's girls that need that.
They need you to take the
poster. They need you to fuck
the shit out of him. Dude,
I get it. I need you to talk to
them or I need you to grab them.
You need to fucking start pulling
their hair. Choke them bit.
You gotta start doing squats.
I liked the live smack and
squats and eat a lot of buffalo.
If you can get some bison in you, maybe
some ostrich, some meaty red shit. Steady.
Right? If you could find on elk Cyrex,
sorry, I should go to fid. Rutgers.
Kill a deer with your fucking
hands is what you need to do.
You need to go on one of those Indian
vision quests where you go running down
a a d or until it dies of exhaustion and
then you eat it's heart
while it's still beating.
And then then he'd go back and fuck the
shit out of her with the blood all over
your chest but not at night until
you finish fucking the deer. Yeah.
Fuck the deer first just for a warmup
just to get your kinks worked out of your
Dick and then you'd go back home.
No sense in going in gold. Yeah.
How do you make noises
when you're making love?
I can understand chick
open the fucking door.
Knowing the background you're
making brother dead animal
on the ground and youth
howl through a conch shell.
That's what you do. Do.
You step in and you fucking take care of
business so that, but when you do that,
that kills the making love aspect
of your fighting. Here's the deal.
Only fosters a deal buddy.
Here's the deal.
Fucking the last thing you would ever
want, right is a girl who is like,
like acting like a dude and
talking shit to you. And you know,
and being all manly with you and you know,
you don't want to be the sub aggressive
with you or getting weird with you rank
that would be grossed.
Right. Well, with some girls,
some girls are very girly, they're
very sexual, they're very bright.
And with those girls they want a lot of
man. They want a lot of shit happening.
Right. They don't want you to just be like
whimpering on top of them and shooting
loads. Yeah. They don't
want you cuddling up.
They don't want you and
twitching every now and then.
You've got to give them what
their DNA needs, cut, talked,
and you don't want to lean and go
to them. I'm sorry. That hurt. Yeah.
Just when date after, after it's done
and you're gonna apologize. Exactly.
Sorry about calling you. They make
a crazy moment as it normal also,
that girls always say that they must
be like starting their period again.
But you think it's because you,
you rip them what's going on in your life.
It's like every time I have sex with
a girl, they're like, oh my God,
it started again. Or, ah, but I think
I'm ripping them. What would be a huge,
I didn't think so many girls
at this happened to it.
Like they're always
saying that it hurts them.
I'm going too deep and it's hurting.
I've never had a problem with her.
You measure your deck or you had, do
you have some crazy dick? All right,
and here's an, here's another truth. How
big is your do not that big. Like six,
seven inches. That's terrible, right?
That's a sad deck. I gotta say it like,
but it's, it's girthy. Normal's like six
inches, right? This isn't that normal.
I don't know. Oh, look
and think that that might,
you're being a dick that's making me,
I don't even want to look
at your fingers right now.
I just see a dick for some
reasons. Get your finger
Dixon. Well, maybe you're just,
you're just lucky and you dated
a bunch of shallow vagina girls.
That's what I'm thinking. I think
that's a shallow vagina. Goes.
Now here's another question. Do you get,
have you ever had sex in the shower?
Is it, does it make you
dizzy? No reason. No,
but this always makes me like the other
day I you pass out in the shower while
you're fucking two months ago I'm
having sex and I'm like, like,
like within like a minute. I'm like,
all right, I'm getting lightheaded.
And I had to go lay down. I had to
go lay down on the bathroom floor.
And then the substitute
nick walked in the talk.
Was this after she had told you
she wanted you to talk to her? No,
this is somebody else's,
uh, Asian, black girl and
said, but, but like, like,
like within a minute like that happens.
But if like it was outside of the shower.
Oh no problem at all. Good
as long as you want. But,
but immediately when I'm in a shower,
it's like, what is that about?
Take it back to the same standard
can kill an elk with a Bowie knife.
You need to jump on his fucking back and
hold on to his horns and cut his throat
as you,
you get your,
your guard wrapped around his neck and
trips to the ground as he runs out of
blood. That's what you need to do.
You need to fucking kill something.
Sign when you get them from behind,
stretch the body so your DNA is getting
watered down by technology in the
universe. You need to take a log
and run up a hill with it. Okay?
You're losing your fucking cells.
They're going away.
And why did fading?
Is it normal for them?
Put the phone next to the pill and they
have their parents listen to you have sex
on her wedding night. Just kidding.
I forgot to get coconut water.
What are you talking about? You just had
one. I know I'm thirsty. Stuff. Oh, okay.
I get a lot. Another one. You
Freak. I'm going to cut him off.
No more marijuana. No more coconut water.
I don't think marijuana's the problems.
Coconut water. Coconut water is
delicious. The marijuana gets some crazy.
We've got to get you on some elks blood.
That's where you're going to do.
You're going to start drinking elks
blood just a couple of days a week.
Small glass of eligibilities.
Yeah, no edit Nami. That's shit.
Mommies. That edamame may shit makes
you grow tits that makes she estrogen.
Yeah. Soy, especially that
genetic genetically modified soy.
That shit will fuck you
eight ways to Sunday.
Who knows what's going on with that?
He does that also. I don't know.
I'm talking out of my ass.
I know nothing about vegetable growth.
Benched a little girl.
I don't think you're an agricultural
knowledge is disappointing. Joe Soc.
Sprout socks. I don't even
know what a silo is for. I
think they keep grain in it.
Yes. They keep grain. And if you ever
hear about people dying in silos,
like they fall off and they just drowned
by going right down the middle of the
silos. Grain drown. Yeah.
Grain drown captain that corn so much.
Oh my God.
How do they get you out? Uh, I
don't know. I did. They asked.
They start from the bottom. So somebody
has a lot of starch in the Diet.
You can't swim either. Right? Right.
You're just fucking corn everywhere in
your mind. God, that must be horrifying.
I'm always, I'm, I was
always fearful of those, uh,
those ball things that you throw
kids in the little balls. Yeah. Yeah.
There's one thing that my,
uh,
my two year old has this gymnastics
class she goes to and there's a pit they
jump into and it's all filled with
these little spongy foam things.
And I jumped into it. I'm
like, I don't like this at all.
Like this feels like you
can't get outta here.
Like it might be fun if you're 25 pounds,
you know, if you're a two year old,
but when you're a grown man and you fall
all these balls, like this is stupid.
Like why would anybody think this is fun?
And they're dirty, dirty mother fuckers.
I do miss like laser tag though.
Do you guys ever
played laser tag but at once was
pretty dope. I should say the bomb.
They need to bring that back.
Yeah. Well they stopped it. Yeah.
Well I don't know the place. There's a
place out here, man fog and everything.
There's a place yet. It's not out here.
It's about 45 minutes away north. But, uh,
I'll take you, we can
go something like, yeah,
that's you and me and Ari and Julie to
watch on the sidelines and then we'll
wait in line for a cabbage
patch. Kid Joel, join into man.
What the fuck are you asking me?
Don't you know what my real name is?
If he goes to the couple laser
tag champion has for you bro. Uh,
you know my wife's last name is Diaz.
Really? If you're related a
wonderful wonder, he is holy Shit.
But you could also be related to Nick
Diaz if you had to choose between being
related to Nick Diaz and being
related to Joey Diaz, Nate Diaz,
you'd go names that the neck.
But Nate and nick are the same.
That's the same lineage to saint brothers.
What the fuck?
Cock sucker stopped doing. My voice
shitty. He's Puerto Rican, right? Joey?
Joey is Cuban always a Cuban. Does your
wife Puerto Rican? No, she's Ecuadorian.
Oh Damn. She Ran Honduran. Cause you've
got yourself a job. I got myself on as
I watched this crazy fucking,
yeah.
I don't like those ancient ancient aliens
show. You know, you've watched those.
A lot of them were kind of Hokey, but
I watched one last night that was dope.
Which one?
The one all about unexplained structures.
Yeah, but this, uh, about the masons
and the Menotti and everything and the,
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no. It wasn't about that. It
was about structures like a,
in Peru, these gigantic
stone walls that they built,
these are like hundred ton stones
and they were carved into place.
So they fit like a puzzle and they fit
perfectly and they fit to the point where
you can't even get a piece of paper in
between the rocks and they have no idea
how they did this,
how they quarried them,
how they moved them thousands
and thousands of years ago.
These just massive walls.
I've been watching a lot of lately.
Incredible Shit,
man.
Big Alien. Shitted out Joe.
Well, that's what these guys are.
Everyone's always claiming it's aliens.
You know that the Lizard Aliens, right?
Yes.
The reptilian aliens.
It's really silly thinking, but
it's sexy thinking. You know,
people love the idea of everything
being aliens. Man. There was aliens.
Aliens did this, don't
you see? But we're aliens.
If you look at the regular primates and
you look at us, we are fucking aliens.
We know that.
We come up with crazy shit now,
isn't it a much more likely
scenario that we have been us,
we have been this thing for a long ass
time and that we have been this thing for
maybe hundreds of thousands of years and
then we've been wiped out a few times.
That's much more likely.
We had to, yeah, the much,
much more like there's no way that we
were around for this long and then all of
a sudden in 100 years made
fucking strides letter.
Well,
there's so much evidence that we,
that things get wiped out
all the time on earth.
We know that there was at
least two mass extinctions,
one to 50 million years ago,
one 65 million years ago where
everything's dead except like a couple of,
you know,
some bugs and some rats and shit and
they figured out how to become everything
there is now. If you believe in
all that, you take God. It's got,
have happened in smaller ways
and just fucked up everyone.
It's must've happened.
This shit that killed off the dinosaurs.
It doesn't mean that it
just kills everybody.
It doesn't mean that they're
the mass extinctions.
That's the only way they happen.
It also could mean they killed almost
everybody and there weren't as bad as the
dinosaur one,
but a lot of people fucking died and
they left behind a lot of crazy shit that
they had already accomplished.
And then everybody else
basically started with scratch.
We started with whatever knowledge we
had been passed on to by our forefathers.
Whatever was in our head.
That's what we got.
And then we figured out how to rebuild
houses and hunt for food and we go
through the whole thing all over again.
That's more likely. That's more likely.
Where are you with 2012? I am
about a year and a half away, man.
Come on buddy.
It was,
you fucking left yourself that not even
a year and a half year. Two years a day.
Well two December 21st. Yeah. Um,
I think here they a miscalculated
the date though. That's a lot of,
they don't know. The speculation is
one scarred like a hundred years off.
Wow. I've heard it's more safe
than I've heard. It's not,
there's a lot of problems with um,
interpreting what the Mayans said and
what they really meant. You know, what a,
a myon, Myon, alphabet.
The way it works is each image,
uh,
depicts a sound or a word and
like a word, you know, like the,
like the way like things were like they
would show you like a heard someone
describe it this way.
Um, it would say, uh,
I saw aunt rose would be an eyeball,
uh,
saw an aunt and a rose.
That's how you would say I saw at rose.
You'd have to say it like that though.
That's the other language.
I think Mckenna said that or
explain that that way. Um, and um,
so when they tried to like decipher
a lot of the old Maya and shit,
like it's really tricky. I watched this
documentary on breaking the mind code.
Like their language was so
different than ours. Like so alien.
It's so hard to say like in English what
these guys wrote down in these images
and drawings. It's like, man,
there's a lot of like filling in the
blanks and guesswork and just just in the
translation, you know, just,
just trying to translate it.
It's like you might be getting
the same feeling and what they're,
they're saying but might not.
So there's so much speculation
of what does it mean?
What is the end of the count,
what is this?
And then what a lot of people believe
is all it is is there's a procession of
the equinoxes and it's a
26,000 something year cycle.
And what it is is that the
earth wobbles on its access,
doesn't spin perfectly and it create a
completes this wobble every in 26,000
years or something like that. I
think it's that much, isn't it? Um,
whatever the number is, but that, this
is what it was all based. And this is,
these are these cycles based on,
but it doesn't necessarily mean that
anything happens, you know, I mean in,
in just because they wrote it down and
made a cycle and a calendar and there's
counts in the calendar and that this is
the end of the long count. December 21st,
2012 unit. That is the day. It doesn't
mean that anything happens, you know,
there's all these people like there's
going to be a great awakening and we are
all going to come join in one
consciousness and experience mother Gaia.
She will speak to us again as she has not
in thousands of years since the Mayans
last saw her, her, her
society in our lights,
in our electricity,
in our sis sis prescription medicine
is a ruined our connection to the great
mother maybe or maybe you're a crazy con
and you believe in palm reading and you
just need your life to
be more interesting.
That being some fat fucking cheese doodle,
Eaton Weirdo that sitting at home,
you know, watching ancient aliens on
TV. Maybe. Maybe that's not the answer.
Maybe 2012 nothing happens.
Most likely it's likely,
but maybe it's some sort
of a technological thing.
Maybe it's nothing. Maybe.
Maybe it is what mostly singularity.
I mean like seriously like what are the
odds are hundreds that other planet,
they said he was going to hit us and can't
Brian, but you can't say that we are,
we aren't on a very clear path.
Yeah,
but do you really think that this
day is going to happen and then like
everything's going to, something crazy
is going to happen for real. Look,
if something crazy happens,
okay,
and if it happens a a decade from
now or if it happens tomorrow,
what's going to happen is
going to be so fucking nuts.
You are going to completely be over the
fact that someone called the day that he
nailed it December 21st he was right.
What are the odds?
You're not going to care what the odds
were because what's going to happen is
going to be so fucking world blowing or
what's going to happen is something like
a time machine or a portal to another
dimension or some sort of experience
interdimensional experiences that people
be able to go through or wormholes or
it's something fucking completely crazy
that we can't even wrap our heads around
now because it's beyond our comprehension.
That's what's going to happen
and when that does happen,
you're not going to give a fuck if it
was in December or July, I was there.
They're going to say, look
man, we've connected all time
together in one grouping.
You can dive in but you
can't dive out who's with me.
If you go and you have to realize
that your identity dissolves,
you no longer exist and you
become one of the great mind,
do you do it or do not do it?
I called the day.
I knew it was going to be July 13th look,
I wrote it down.
No one's going to give a fuck if you
wrote it down. You dumped con you in,
are you not in? Yeah, but that simple.
So you're thinking that that's gonna
happen in your lifetime though.
Something crazy, you know, dig
it that absolutely. Absolutely.
The singularity will happen
within our lifetime. There's,
it's inevitable unless some sort of a
natural disaster occurs before that.
If something occurs before then and knocks
us back, you know, to, who knows? Man,
maybe that's the earth's and knock
culation system. Maybe the earth is like,
listen bitch, we're not ready for you
to make the black hole machine yet.
So the Earth fucking an asteroid
our way. Boom. I mean maybe the,
we don't think of the sky
being a natural system,
but maybe it isn't natural system.
You know, maybe just like, you know,
bacteria is here to kill off
the old people, you know, and,
and strong colds in one of
those. Therefore, what does
that, that battle with the,
these invisible forces that kill our
loved ones. What is that about? Well,
that's a system, man. It's a whole
system in place. I mean, you can call it,
you know, you could call it bacteria,
you can call it germs. You can call it,
there's a system. Okay? The system is
when you get weak, someone gets you. Okay.
And it might be a the flu and might be
leukemia, whatever the fuck it might be.
There's some crazy biological system.
Well,
the main that might exist in
the software system as well.
The dinosaurs might've
just got to fucking crazy.
It might've just been too nuts and the
hole geological system was so fucking off
balance like no one's ever going to
invent anything. Okay? Here's why.
Every time you go outside a 90 foot
lizard eats your asshole, okay?
No one is going to ever invent shit.
We've got to kill these motherfuckers.
And progress comes to a screeching halt
because there's these super predators.
I mean they are the
epitome of Super Predator.
Look at the t rex giant fucking thick
skin lizard monster with huge teeth at
each all day.
Nothing ever gets done like that.
So you've got to come up with a child and
500 mile wide chunk of iron from space
go and 45,000 miles and hour slamming
into the cross and just fucking everything
up. Just fucks the whole Party
man, and when that happens,
then everything gets to start again
and maybe we're just going to,
they've rebooted.
Yeah.
Maybe we're going to get to some point
where we're just so retarded and out of
control and overpopulated that were
piled on top of each other and then maybe
the universe reboots us.
I think people were waiting 20s thought
the same thing probably though. Yeah,
but they were right. They were
just wrong by the day. The,
but the difference between 1920 2010 in
your life is a long time in the life of
the universe. That ain't shit. Okay.
They recognize an ethic and they
sought an advance. That's what it is.
They just were wrong about the date when
they thought the apocalypse was coming
10,000 years ago. They were right. Okay.
They were just off by 10,000
years and 10,000 years isn't shit,
but everybody was paying attention.
If you look at the direction
that human beings are going,
we all recognize it's
going to some crazy point.
That's not a fucking bright future.
There's no way. There's no way.
If population keeps increasing
and increasing and increasing,
and we keep polluting and polluting and
fighting and war in Iran gets nuclear
weapons, we got issues, some shit's
going to go down. It's inevitable.
And everybody recognized that
back in the biblical days.
They recognize that 500 years ago they
recognized that in the 1920s and they
were right. They were right. It's
just, that's the way it's moving.
It just takes time. So that's what
all this 2012 shit is, you know,
whether it's 2012 or
when Jesus comes back,
I've got these fucking videos that
are awesome. Okay? They are all,
it's Kirk Cameron series, their VHS. You
gotta get, I gotta buy them on Vhs, man.
That's awesome. They
are. And it's uh, it's,
I forget what they're fucking calls like
a crazy Christian though. Right beyond,
he believes the rapture that is going to
happen when Jesus is going to come back.
All the beautiful people that love Jesus
is going to disappear and they're going
to leave us stranded in hell.
The hell of earth,
the God like God is going
to come and take away.
He believes basically that God is like
an alien who's going to take all his,
his brother's back to the mothership.
He's fucked.
How nutty is that concept? And people
who know it's not an alien moon.
It's the rupture.
It's going to take us to heaven.
We're going to live forever with love.
It's not like aliens.
You're going to heaven. You're going
to space. You're leaving this planet.
You're going to disappear.
We're not.
No little God is going to
remove us from no you dude,
you might as well be beaming
a board. Okay, you're,
you're using magic and you're going to
go to some special place and you don't
think that's nuts. These videos
are awesome. They're awesome,
and he really sells them in
the videos. Oh yeah, man,
these people are believe in this man.
It's a window into madness and it's all
based. Like there's a, there's a, um,
there's a whole book series that's
written by these two dudes that right,
these apocalyptic,
you know,
rapture books and they sell like crazy.
God,
I'm going to have to Google this now
because I don't remember the name of this
guy. It's kind of
important. Um, because uh,
the whole idea is pretty fucking
interesting. What's your religion man?
Are you religious or nonreligious?
Left behind. That's what it's about.
These are the books that I was raised
Catholic though, where I was two.
That's good enough. Right? Catholic like
inoculates you, cause it's so silly,
you know? Ridiculous. Yeah.
And everybody's fucking everybody and
hitting their money and shit. You know,
you don't really such a ridiculous,
when I look at it now, I'm like, really?
You're going to believe some of this
shit, any of this shit. Really? Yeah.
It's like, it's so ridiculous. Who wrote
this book? Yeah, the left behind series.
You've got to check it out. They
may, I think they made two videos.
I'm pretty sure how both of them,
if I don't, I'm going to buy them.
If they come out with new ones, I'm
buying them to Blu ray there. Awesome.
Ingredia Unintentional Kirk Cameron
on Ray, three day can occur.
Came as curly hair will come. So if you,
if you were raised Catholic, you know,
I have all this Indian art around my
house and you were very aware of what all
this shit is and you are very aware of,
you know,
what the names for them and everything
like that. How do you know all that stuff?
That's still, my parents
are from India. Right?
So you used to know things you go when
you go to visit family and stuff you
would see not in their houses,
but like you would see it around India.
And I'd ask what is that?
What does that,
it needs a pretty fascinating fucking
country when you think about the history
of all these weird fucking really
thoughtful things have come out of India.
You know, just uh, the, the,
the history of Yoga, you know,
in the Yogis and the
sod dues and you know,
all those dudes sitting around smoking
chillums and trying to figure out the
universe and you know,
the hot vogue Eda and,
or Mahabharata
and um, you know, what is, um, what
is the fucking, there was another one,
another ancient texts. It's
really fascinating. She
stayed in my hot Parada's.
What are those like little breads,
their breads,
little Paratas and mom would make them,
when was the first time you saw
a chicken that wasn't red? Huh?
Chicken. It wasn't reg. Reg Chicken. Red
Chicken. The Indian chicken. Yeah. Oh,
turn dirty red chicken.
The BHAGAVAD Gita, right.
That's what it's called. The new
book. The ancient Hindu book.
What Oppenheimer quoted after you
fucking blew up the atomic bomb,
which is very nice. So you got fucking
wild. That was never a religion though.
You know, it was just a
way of life. Really. Yeah.
And then somebody wrote it
down and became a religion.
It's almost like if somebody said,
uh,
wrote down the rules to yoga and
then people started following it,
like a religious will. They
do. Yeah. Right. So look,
I know people that are younger people,
you know,
they classify themselves as yoga people.
They might as well be in a cult.
I mean they really might as well be.
I mean it's very beneficial and it's
helping them a lot. Certainly helps. Like,
they all, they all have great energy and
they're all like really friendly people.
But it's, um, it's, it's, might
as well be a cult, you know,
it's like sort of the same sort of thing.
They start talking and there's one chick,
you fucking ring your phone again, dude.
No, that's wrong with you. What was
that? Zoom and sound like a song. Huh?
This one. Any religion though,
the minute it gets written down,
it becomes a religion I guess.
But I mean the yoga thing is a
fascinating thing because it really,
but it really is, is some sort of
a body maintenance thing, you know,
they figured out how to maintain your
body in maintaining like your health and
maintain like a certain
certain sense of clarity.
And a lot of that shit came out of
India. Man. A lot of that shit, you know,
came out of the, uh, you know, the, the,
like a lot of the ancient India
way of way of life, like with,
with the saw do's and with these, uh,
these yogis. And I always wonder like,
why this one area, you know, if you look
at all these different areas of Europe,
all these different areas like India
especially has a lot of like really trippy
shit that came from India.
Like all your artwork,
the Indian artwork and not your artwork.
I'll yet people, you know, you people,
the Canadian Indian artwork is all so
fascinating, man. It's all really trippy.
Like, you know, she Eva's with, you know,
they're fucking six arms and shit and
like, it's all really, really bizarre.
Like psychedelic heady stuff
I talked about. It's a,
it's a very state of mind
country. Yeah. When you go there,
I talk about it and funny
enough in my act, but um,
no, I'm good. Thanks.
Did you happen to see that Yogi bear
parody where Yogi kills a booboo?
No. Did you see that? So
talk about nonsequitors.
You mother fucker ever talking
about India? Well, trippy MD.
We're talking about yoga.
Yoga. This is yoga. That is
not what we're talking about.
I'm not talking about Yogi bear.
I,
he's brought that up because
no one was saying anything.
So, oh, I see. Oh, why was
it saved us clever things to say
about those index. Good. Safe.
Why don't you try yoga, Brian? Maybe
that'll bring it job fucking hard, dude.
I done it a few times. It's great.
Especially if you're single.
It's the best place ever to go to meet
girls and see they're buttholes and stuff.
See their bottles. Just see him move
around. They're barely wearing anything.
Especially you get the hot sweaty one.
They're like, it's, it's just amazing.
It's just naked chicks pretty much.
And it's naked chicks that looking
out for their health. Yeah. Right.
So they're healthy, naked, good bronze.
Yeah. Especially the eat like good stuff.
Eat good food.
Right.
You know what? Some chicken hot dogs all
the time with that stinky as beer pussy.
Yeah, totally. But too much vegetables,
micro farts thing. So yeah. Really? Yeah.
More than meat. I don't know.
I find vegetarian Scully,
vegetarians have the worst far
too ever. Oh my God. Oh Man.
I guess eve you think about it
until like one vegetables rot. Yeah.
Shit is terrible. Meet Roddick
smells worse. It's got to
smell worse, man. You know,
it's really gross. It's not meet Rod.
I challenged. I was challenged by a,
I was defining it in my head by thickness.
You've never smelled my
friend Tate Fletcher's farts.
Now I'm kind of great shit.
Really do that. Sometimes you don't
even know what you're talking about son.
You think you do you think you know,
smelling farts like when you get like
one of these UFC motherfuckers farts on,
you rotate dudes who are digging pro tubs,
the synthesix all day and I try to
stay a maintain it about two 39,
239 pounds of muscle and they fought
and just clear out buildings. Yep. Yep.
Yo our friend Tate. I always
find the better, uh, the shape.
The persons in the worst. Their farts
are really, it's cause the protein man,
they a lot of protein that should
cakes up inside you and formed pockets.
Just stews and then finally
comes out in a gaseous form.
I've been having some pretty bad
ones lately. I don't know why.
And I keep reviewing my
diet and my head and go,
what the fuck is causing this dead
animal in my body to come out?
I love Indian food man.
And if you eat Indian food,
you know there's a place
down the street from me.
You know the reason why you
know your farts smell that way.
Like when you smell Indian food,
Indian food farts are very specific to,
because they're very normal to me.
See for me in our house it'd be like
somebody with a partner would smell.
My Dad boy who ate macaroni and
somebody's been eating shit in this house
in fifth grade they let a hamburger in
fifth grade.
Our teachers actually had to pull the
whole class aside cause our one Indian guy
named Omar for sure they had they,
I guess everyone made fun of his farts
cause they smelled different than owners
and so they had to like explain to our
class when he was out in the hallway that
do not make fun of him. He eats, he
has a special diet and they have,
that's hilarious.
I remember that clear as day Port Omar,
if you're out there religious
special diets or the other
shit man, I have a buddy of mine that
was, makes me lucky and he was a fighter.
He was a taekwondo fighter and
he used to on Ramadan, you know,
you're not allowed to,
I don't know exactly what the masses,
you fast until sun down down.
You think you're allowed to drink
water, right? Nothing. Yeah. I don't even
think you could do shit. And so, you know,
he would still compete even though
he had to do this, you know,
but it would just just wreck him
physically. He was just useless, you know,
like it didn't, one of them was there a
basketball player that did that as well.
There was like a famous basketball player,
Chemo Xuan I believe it was,
was it him? I don't remember what it was
cause I'm not really a basketball fan,
but it was one shut up man.
There was one famous basketball
player who used to do this.
He's to the Robin Don
thing and he couldn't eat.
Then he would go play basketball suck.
They're like, whenever the fucking,
you know, people would get pissed off
and over Ramadan would come around.
I don't remember who it was, but uh, it's,
it's weird when people stick so fucking
rigidly to like weird little rules.
Like that about eating. You know,
like, yeah, I don't get that.
That's a luxury of people
that have too much food.
If that's what you're coming up with,
you should be just eating to stay healthy.
All right. Stop. Stop with the, you know,
if you're going to fucking love God,
go love God. You don't have to love God
with your food. You fucking freak. Yeah.
You have to deny yourself
a food when you have it.
Jesus Christ who put the food there.
If you believe in God,
don't you think he'd put the food in
your life? He wants you to eat it.
You fuck it doesn't want you to
starving yourself all day for his love.
He made the whole universe.
He you think he's impressed with
you starving yourself all day,
dear God, I did not eat that pig
today. Yeah, it gave me the eye.
I'm addicted to Crock pots right
now. Really? Tell me what's so nice.
You just throw chicken in there.
Put some lemons in there. Wait,
six hours later you have like
our real hardcore meal, you know,
hardcore chicken and lemon in a
crockpot. Yeah, the old south.
Delightful. I'm staking some
vegetables in there. Bam.
You got these steps a difference in
you and I right there in a nutshell.
I like cooking over fire
when it's cold outside.
Outside. Yeah. Like, and I like real wood,
but what you're talking about Goldie
three here, it's been 83 here in la.
40. I used to like do it in Colorado,
but I did it with a gun in my pocket.
But I lived in Colorado because I
was cooking meat outside, you know,
with fucking wild animals. I
lived in the woods. Dude. I know.
I remember when you left. Yeah,
I lived there for a few months.
If it wasn't for the wife, I'd still
be out there. I remember you, uh,
listened to our one podcast when
we were talking about third base.
Remember he was texting at the time.
It's right, right. What was it?
What was the issue that came
out and I can't remember.
You guys were looking for the name of
pace that that leads to search [inaudible]
Minister Pete. Nice Prime
Minister Pete. Nice.
And there was in search and Richie
rich, I believe was their Dj. Yeah,
those guys were good dude.
Why? What happened to them?
How come they disparage started a clothing
company and why did he stop rapping?
I don't know. You can't
wrap forever. Why can't you?
Why not to stand up? There's only
so many and do stand up forever.
You can't be too successful and
just keep wrapping. You know?
Why not babies? I don't
know. Why can't you? I
know. It's a young man's sport.
This rapping. It's like a,
it's almost like an a
a sport. Really? Yeah.
Why is it is because the young man are,
we appreciate a certain amount of swagger
and cockiness and confidence in young
men when we see it. An
old man. It's stupid.
Especially men that aren't too old yet.
Yeah.
We'll accept it again once you hit 90
yeah, exactly. You know, it's like
watching old fighters. You're like, man,
I remember when you were good. He
slowed down. Yeah. You're not going to,
reflexes aren't the same.
What was that her days?
Oh,
that's one of the weirdest things ever
is watching a fighter deteriorate. Very,
very strange thing. God dammit. Jeff,
you mother fuckers is m yes it is.
I'm doing a podcast,
I'll tell you about pop goes.
Yeah, that was a good one.
That was a, they were,
see this is like one of
the first hater songs.
They were upset at a vanilla ice
getting paid. Oh, that's right. Yeah.
For turning this out.
Turn this up.
That's right. He's dressed up as
vanilla ice. The complaint is,
I should have started when was against
phony phony entertainers like what
they're doing is valid bulletin veil.
Isis doing was not paid.
It's 91 so something's got to change
10 years ago.
Pick the music and makes sense.
This mom around my mom and met Milli
Vanilli one week before they got caught in
the elevator, they, they
showed an hour later
go legally linked to go with the
ways of the week. No Angelo surface.
No. Who's that friend of mine,
comedian. Him and him and Joey.
I was end up going out for the same
roles because they same size. Right.
So Angela was flying to South Africa.
Whoa.
And he gets on the plane and this guy
sits beside him up in business class and
he's like, and the guy says, send
again, it looks into this, hey man, I,
I recognize you were a comedian,
right? And he goes, oh yeah, hey,
it goes and then you go, it looks enemy.
And he goes, Holy Fuck, it's K Fed, right?
It's like, okay, that's
cool. Kevin Federline,
the guy used to be married to a
British man. So he's like, oh,
they're talking the whole flight. And
he's like, what are you going here for?
I'm shooting a commercial for something
and cause yeah, I'm doing the show.
You should come to my show and blah
blah blah. All right Kev. All right.
In the guys k fed was doing a
commercial was the story here.
So they invite them to the show and he
shows up to the show and he's backstage
with all his friends and he's like,
hey guys,
this is a k fed and just cut me
rob. And he's like, all right,
that's k fed. And then I'm at a med was
with him and he, I met him and polls goes,
hey, that's not kayfabe.
That's vanilla ice.
[inaudible]
wow.
You know what son of a bitch.
It's like you had to be
painful for Vanilla ice cause
then he realizes that he's
in that category of town
famous who you make fun of,
but they're right here so
you don't make fun of them.
I have a slight possibility to
sleep with Britney spears zone.
Well he definitely did that.
You know,
in the right category still vanilla ice
was like legit superstar performer for a
short period of time. Had a few big
hits. Scott that do it yourself.
Sean has come up. Do you
remember what Vanilla I, he does.
He's a renovation show on like the HGTV.
Really understand. That's hilarious.
Do you remember when a vanilla
ice boxed Todd, what did he do?
Did he bought Todd bridges? Todd bridges
beat the fuck out of Vanilla ice horse.
Of course.
Sort of bridges is black.
That and the other guys trying to be
black and now he's doing [inaudible].
It's always any kind of trying
to be blind. For instance,
I have a real black blacks,
always real black.
Oh Dude, that's, there
is some logic and science
to what you just said. Yes, of course.
A guy who's trying to be black,
talking to a guy who's black
fighting. So true. So true.
There's no way he could win. Never. He
should have known going into that contest,
still
can deliberately newsy.
Maybe thought that Todd bridges was
a fake black because he was a child
celebrity and he was on different strokes,
raised by a white,
but he was only raised by a white
on TV and not collated from that.
All that Hollywood shit crack cleaned
them out of that crack, cleaned that out,
and brought him back to his roots ghetto,
back to his inner ghetto tide had Dana
on this side too. Not White either.
Plato. Mm. That was a,
that's a disturbed show, man.
When you look at all the things that
happened to those people on that show,
you got to go, Whoa, what the fuck,
Tom?
He's the last man standing.
Yeah,
and and Dana Plato all fucked up.
Huge celebrities on TV.
Everybody's had them and now he's doing
ICDC commercials. What does that mean?
I is it ICDC? Yeah, the
College Community College,
we had them on the fear factor who
was, um, it was a very angry guy. Man.
There's some dudes where you,
you like you're hanging out with them and
you're talking to them or whatever and
you go, oh, okay, I can, I
can tell you in 10 minutes,
90% of what's wrong with your life.
It's the way you're fucking acting man.
Who's like a spoiled child.
Like when he lost and he got eliminated
from the shell, he goes, okay.
Oh, I see what's up. I see what's
up. You guys don't want me to win.
Like he was like, like a child and
he was like a man in his thirties.
I went to shake his hand and need the
cockroaches. I wanted to shake his hand.
Yeah, exactly. He wouldn't shake hands
me. And I'm like, okay, good, good.
I'm glad. I'm glad to get out of here.
Who Was it? That one episode where the
guy wanted to, we had to slap down. Yeah.
Oh yeah, there was a couple, there
was a couple. And they've, they've,
they've fought with each other all the
time and screamed and yell at each other
like one, one time on a, on a show.
He had thrown her to the ground.
I'm one of the shows and another
reality show they were on.
So we had been told that this guy was
like violent and they could be dangerous.
And so, um, we, uh,
we did the show and the girl had been
taunted the whole time the show is going
on. It was the guy, the guy's name was,
um, Jonathan and I forget what his wife's,
Victoria was, his wife.
And there was another kid,
the dude who got fucked up by Danny
Bonaduce once he was on survivor,
Johnny, fuck, I can't
remember his name. Anyway,
Johnny. Anyway, what happens was
this kid is an awesome shit talker.
And while they were off,
they're doing their stunts.
He was like screaming at them,
Jonathan, you can do better.
She's dead weight. She's dead weight
man. And she's holding you back.
And it was really funny,
man,
because they were frustrated and yelling
and screaming at each other and he was
like dumper, and she was like, Yo,
shop. And he's like, you see this man,
this is bad energy, dude.
You don't need this.
And so he's like totally torturing
them while they're don't go into their
stunting, they're fucking up and
they can't find their flashlight.
It's a disaster. Right? So when, when
they come back, after they got eliminated,
the girl walks up to this Johnny kid,
Johnny fucking forget his name and
punches him. Just straight up hits him.
And I go, Whoa, Whoa, what the fuck?
You can't assault people
trying to fairplay thank you.
That's him. And I'm like,
just because you,
you fucking hit your husband doesn't
mean you can hit other people.
And then the husband goes,
hey.
And he gets in my face and all I could
think to say was, no, hey, hey, hey.
He says, hey, hey, hey. So I said, no.
All I can think of is this guy's
going to hit me. Like for sure.
He was a total loose cannon and he was
screaming and yelling at his wife just
seconds ago,
and now he's like in my face and I'm like,
this guy easily could hit me. So
I shoved him away from me. I said,
get the fuck out of my face. Don't
touch me, don't come close to me.
And then he came back again and he goes,
touch me again.
And then I just pushed him again
and then I grabbed his head.
Then I grabbed the back of his head
and I just held onto them. I was like,
if he hits me,
I'm going to nee is fucking brain
into another part of the universe,
but I'm not going to do anything
until he tries to hit me.
So I just held onto him, but I was
convinced that he was going to hit me.
It was like, you just go straight.
Held him down on, anyway,
I just grabbed the back of his head.
I got him in a Thai clinch,
has grabbed the back of his head. I
just, it was right there, just grab it.
I was like, I wasn't gonna choke him. I
thought about choking him, but I'm like,
if I choke them,
then I've done something to them.
Right now I'm just holding
onto him. Oh, sorry.
I just grabbed a hold of his head and I
just handled them until they pulled us
apart. But no, nothing ever
happened. But it was, uh, it's,
it's weird when there's someone that's
that dangerous at someone's, that,
that has that little control over their,
their physicality and their emotions.
Those are usually the guys that I've
never been punched in their face usually.
Yes.
Usually guys that I was run off with,
the lips never been punched in the mouth.
Usually he completely panicked.
Once I grabbed him, he went like a
child. He didn't know what to do.
He didn't know to hit me or push me away.
So he didn't do anything.
He kind of just flailed his arms in
this weird, like panicky moving thing.
You know, most people are
not used to conflict like
conflict. When you do Jujitsu,
you know, you used to physical conflict
all the time. It's like a normal thing.
Just, it's not, it doesn't seem unnatural.
But for a lot of people
don't fucking hyperventilate.
Like I've seen people in the street street
fights just straight hyperventilate,
freak out and not know what to do,
not know how to handle themselves.
It's not cool. It's not good to be
around fucking crazy creepy people,
but if you're going to be around
crazy creepy people, it's way better.
If you know how to fight,
the last thing you want is them knowing
how to fight and they're crazy and
creepy and you're the last fucking this
fucking drowning in this ocean of panic.
What are you doing?
Reading
tests? I'm reading, I'm
reading these walks your talk.
One sided conversation where him,
I'm listening and I'm reading
these and maybe we should end this.
Maybe it's time has come. This is
what I did is what happens when every,
every show comes to an end.
Eventually after a while.
Brian, so do it. We're going,
what are we going to keep talking about?
Carlos Newton at the fight
when I was there. Did you I,
I trained with him a couple of times.
How long have you done Jujitsu?
I just used to roll around with the,
there's a comedian named Ron Jostle.
Leta a Canada. Oh yeah, back in
[inaudible] 97 I used to bark.
I stopped boxing in 94 but he wanted to
learn how to strike in [inaudible] 97
and he was doing Jujitsu and I was
like you will never get past the boxer.
Oh that's fun.
And in seconds I was screaming like a
bitch cause he had me in an arm bar.
And so then you learned it? Yeah, I
try trained with them for a little bit.
That's cool. Do you do anything now? No.
That's why I was asking because I
want to go somewhere and do something.
Cause where do you spend the majority
of your time? While on the road.
But I'm gonna be here now for a while.
Okay. Well with the new developments.
Yeah. Where? Well you don't want to
tell me where you live on the air.
Just fucking people are creepy man.
Angeles. Whoa. That's very savvy.
They want to know where you are.
They, where are you Russell?
I need to talk to you.
I tried to look in the bag and have
given you scripts and shit. Yeah,
it didn't have a TV show
coming out. I have, I have a
deal with NBC, but we don't,
you know, waiting on that script.
Right. I don't get any scripts. No.
You don't get any scripts?
What do you mean how?
I mean the agency sends them to me,
but it's not like here they want
you for this film. It's like,
see if you like anything in the here and
then I'll try and get you an audition.
I'm like, yeah, no, I'm good. I'm not
going to start fucking reading things.
Guess it just for the sake of you.
Well, I think that with your
popularity is a comedian.
Doing a sitcom would be a natural thing.
It would just get somebody really good
and write something for you. Totally.
The fuck is wrong with them. Cooking or
writing more time shutting up. Brian,
fuck is wrong with you, Brian. How about
a news radio type of thing? That was,
that was so high. Can my brother,
my brother has every season on DVD.
It's hard to do one of those though.
You got to get the most important things.
You have to have a powerful
writer and a powerful producer.
The guy's got to be good.
They have to good with good sensibilities.
There's just not a lot of them.
There's a lot of them are hand.
You had a lot of good people
and you, yeah. Yeah. You
can get good people though.
There's a lot of good people. You
could do three, four, five, six,
seven casts of good people in La.
You can find a lot of talented
comedic actors, you know,
that could put it into TV shows and if
you figured out how to write specifically
for them, you could have it really good.
It's, you know, a lot of that is luck.
It's really hard as finding the
right writing and find, cause look,
look after news radio,
how many of us went off and did and did
successful sitcoms on our own? None.
None of us did. You know, everyone
tried. I had a couple of pilots.
I had a couple of things
that I was writing and things
that I did or things that
I went up for. It's just, it's too
hard to find something good. You know?
I would get these things and I would
read them and I'd be like, fuck man,
I couldn't do this. Like
this is clunky, dumb,
hacky horseshit and once you do like
a really good show, it's hard man.
So terrible feeling for a stand up to
be doing shitty comedy and might even be
able to change it.
That's a terrible feeling that I get to.
I get that story edit once it's
written, so that's good. Yeah.
You get to the story on it. Oh that's
great man. If you write your own shit,
if you had your own idea and sat
down and came up with your own shit,
that would be the move,
man.
That would be the move because you're the
only guy that really can write for you
and you can't get some fucking dude
who's not really even a standup.
It was like some sort of a,
you've got to find like a really
powerful fucking really bright guy
to news radio but haven't podcasting.
I'm listening and it's our life,
Brian. It's 24 hours a day.
Right. And just because,
I mean if you think
about it like the news,
radio things good like radios are pretty
much dead. Dad seen on the new things,
podcasting have a sitcom
around podcasting and mixed.
It was mixed up with friends.
Maybe have like a little black child,
like different strokes.
That's not a bet. No,
you don't want to go different strokes.
You're on Fox right back then. No.
NBC News Radio.
You see I was on a show on Fox before
that they'll call hardball. That was full.
There was only like seven episodes,
I think aired maybe six [inaudible]
seven shot, terrible show.
And there was a yours? No,
it was, I was the star of it,
but it was a baseball show
on was one of the stars.
There's a bunch of other people
in it. But uh, it was, uh,
it was one of those shows that
was really funny at one point.
And then you got butchered.
The guys who wrote it as guys,
Jeff Martin and Kevin Curran,
they wrote for um, uh,
they wrote for a married with children.
They wrote for the Simpsons. Really,
really funny guys. But the network didn't
think that they could produce a show.
They didn't think that they could, like,
they were hard enough to run a show.
So what they wanted to do was give it to
a producer and that producer took over
and just started rewriting everything
and turned it into their show runner.
Jack that up. Shit, it became dog shit.
Just total hackneyed obvious dog shed.
And um,
that's not fun, you know, and
that's what a lot of happen.
A lot of that happens in Hollywood.
You know,
there's a lot of weird nepotism where
they know that a guy worked on a
successful show. It's like he must have
the magic. He worked on coach. Yep.
You know, so they, they
bring the coach man in. Yeah.
The system, the from called. They
always do that with 10 coach.
They always do that with me. Yeah. You
know, Russell, this is, this is, this is,
this is what we've done before
and it's worked, and I go, well,
clearly everything I've done in my
career is not been the regular. Right,
right.
I didn't get to this level because I fall
on the same path that you think is the,
the, the, the key to success here.
The key to humor too. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. The key to humor is like, man, it's
so hard to gauge one person's humor. Like,
I don't know if I could do it as,
as a comic and a comedian and a writer.
I don't know if I could
take someone else's comedy,
I would have to be so intimate with that
person's comedy till I try to write a,
a plot or an idea for them, like
you're going to get, you know,
your idea of what their ideas would be.
I think Louie CK did it the
best thing I did it, I'm, so,
that's probably the best example
of how to do it. Perfect.
Is that a new show on Fx, right?
Yeah. The new show. Yeah. Yeah.
He totally got it right. I
watched a couple episodes.
He, he's, I love Louie. Yeah,
he's perfect. He's doing exactly the
right way. Why don't you marry him?
You married him. You guys aren't
gonna marry him, ginger babies.
Um, no, we're not going to marry him. I am
Brian.
I think you died 10 minutes ago.
Your body's being run by bacteria.
Coconut water, your body. Yes.
Your body is being run by bacteria that
was living in the coconut water and I
die. It's going to be like aliens where
that robot dyes and all that milk starts
coming out of them. Let me ask you a
question that you already asked me.
What do you think about all
this? 2012 Shit? Um, I dunno.
I keep watching all these things and uh,
what's that? Uh, no. Bureau, that planet,
they said it's going
to hit us. Well, yeah.
Well there they did discover a large
object they believe exists way outside of
Pluto, some large Jupiter sized
object. Have you ever had meat,
you Kako on your show?
No,
but I got a chance to talk to him once
on the opiod Anthony show and ask them a
bunch of questions. He was on the
phone. It's fucking great man.
That guy's awesome. I do love
that guy. He's, he's really smart.
God there's people like him out there.
Yeah.
Cause I don't have that kind of patients,
you know, like these theoretical planes.
Well he's so educated and intelligent
and his whole life has been, you know,
in this pursuit of wisdom. I don't
know if that kind of devotion to shit,
you know,
it's like my,
my thing about so many things is like how
much time would it really take to kind
of understand what the
fuck this guy really knows.
Like when you hear about string theory,
you know,
and you hear about like you
just the idea behind it,
how long would you really have to study
it before you truly understood what the
fuck they're talking about?
I've watched documentaries on string
theory a bunch of times and I never really
know what I'm taking away. But I know
I'm fascinated with the whole time.
Fascinating the whole time. But just
like what you know, there could be,
I watched one with c w with Michio Kaku
where he's talking about there could be
another you and another dimension that
took a left when you took a right and he
went out on a totally different life
journey is happening right now, Simon,
talking about parallel universes and
that there might be an infinite number of
used doing the same life and going in an
infinite number of different directions
all at once. And then there's
the other thought that you, your,
you are traveling and transgressing
through different parallel dimensions all
the time.
And the one you exist in right now is
the one you exist and because of your
choices and literally is not the same
one as the one you started off in,
that you have been with every
decision you make in your life.
You're moving into a new dimension.
You're moving into some new universe,
some new parallel existence.
What the fuck are we talking about?
Folks were talking crazy shit.
Um, I was in Houston. I'm, I'm almost,
I'm so fascinated by the moon
landing thing. Oh, are you? Yeah.
You may as well because I was,
so,
I was in Houston recently and there was
this Indian girl waiting by the bus for
an autograph and a picture.
Very nice, very innocent.
And she was like, I just wanted to take
a picture. She's from India to write.
I was like, cool, no
problems. She goes, you know,
my whole class at the university is
all big fans. I'm like, that's great.
Thank you very much, didn't
you? I go, what are you guys
studying? And she said, uh,
um, astrophysicist. I'm
like, are you kidding me?
I go so well,
like,
what do you mean you designing spacecrafts
who were studying it and we're,
you know, we, yes, we are. That's
ultimately what we're doing. And I said,
so let me ask you a question. Have we
gone to the moon? And she goes, they say,
we've gone to the moon. I go, I
go, what does that mean? Well,
they said, we went to the moon. I go, so
is it possible that we went to the moon?
No, it's not possible that we went
to the moon, but they've said,
we went to the moon.
It's physically impossible to go to
the moon in this day and age. She said,
that is not possible then
how would it be possible now?
What was her reasoning for
saying that it's possible?
She said the van Allen Radiation Belt,
she said it would peel off your skin.
She said, it's not like, you know, it's
not like it would affect your later.
She said it would literally your
skin would fall off. We can't
devil's advocate though.
There are readings of the
Van Allen Radiation Belt
they've released online that
you could find where they show the levels
that are out there and the amount of
exposure to the astronauts would have
gone through if they did what they said
they did.
And there's a bunch of people that
have said that they would survive it.
That's all just on paper though.
My problem with it is they never sent
a fucking chicken in the space and have
that motherfucker come back alive
and they did it with astronauts.
They did it with American civilian
or American, uh, you know,
astronauts during the apex of
a 20 year solar cycle. Really,
you went all the way out there?
Yeah.
Yeah. She said it's just too
far to, it would take too long.
There's no way they got up there and
then send a transmission back that quick
either. Yeah. That's kind of trippy
to, she's like, there's no way.
Like there's just,
it's not physically possible.
What's really trippy is that only did they
do that. They actually timed the, the,
the,
the panning of the camera from,
from Houston to catch the lunar module
as it separates from the moon surface and
they follow it up.
The time the Pan,
like they timed all that on a delay from,
from Houston. Like maybe they did it,
maybe they did it.
She knew I wasn't there.
She literally pointed at my iPhone and
said, you have more technology in this,
true than you did. And all of that.
It's not just about technology,
it's about calculations. It's
about thrust, it's about speed.
It's about catching the,
the, you know, the, the,
the rotation of the movement
coming back along with it.
It's the slingshot effect. And, but I'm
not saying that they, I'm not saying that.
I think they did do it cause
I'm not convinced they went.
But you got to make sure that when
you argue about things like this,
like that the science,
the science is really tricky.
Like you have to know way too much to
really know what the fuck you talking
about. I don't, I don't, but what
I do know is I know bullshit.
Okay. And I'm real good at bullshit. I'm
Mama if you lie to me, man, I can tell.
I can see twitches in your eyes.
I can smell bullshit a mile away.
I've been around so many creeps
my whole life I just fucking,
and just being a comedian and being
a student of the human animal,
when you watch the Apollo 11
press conference when they,
the post flight press conference,
that to me was one of the biggest pieces
of evidence that something's really
wrong because they're
clearly bullshitting.
There's no doubt about it. If you
watch the Apollo 11 press conference,
the post five plus post flight
press conference, they are,
they're talking about this
like, like they're just like
making shit up. It's like,
it doesn't seem like they have any
connection to what they're talking about.
It doesn't seem remotely like it was a
part of their life that you're describing.
It seems like Horse Shit and it seems
like horse shit and they're nervous and
they're answering questions. You
know, it's, we've never gone back.
We've never even come close.
The only time human beings I've ever been
more than 400 miles above the earth's
surface was them. The all
the, uh, the moon missions,
all the ones when they flew over it and
didn't land and the ones that they did
land between 1969 in 1972,
they went and landed and
supposedly and came back. It's far,
it's 250 million or 250,000
miles, which is, think about that.
Think about the fact they did that in
69. Yeah. It doesn't make any sense.
Moving into 2011.
Yeah,
we should have had some
sort of a that's so revisit.
Let's check and see what's that.
If anything's changed up there,
but people look at it, man,
it's like a technological Jesus.
You're not supposed to question it. It's
a deity. It's a technological day day.
Well, yeah, I mean, but at
the same time we're also in,
in the space race with Russia. We
had to beat them at something. Yeah,
but did we even are where we even,
you know, at the highest levels,
and I wonder if,
what if we're going to find out a shit
and wikileaks at the highest levels.
I wonder how much corroboration there
is between governments and I wonder how
much of the fucking Cold War it's just
to keep everybody in line. You know?
Who knows,
who knows how much at the highest level
there was actual real communication and
exchanging of information. You know,
I don't, I don't fucking know, man.
I don't know.
I would not pretend to know.
I know exactly what's going on because
then, you know, people say, well,
if the Russians were weren't in on it,
why didn't they write America out?
I don't know. You know that doesn't mean
they didn't fake it. You know there's,
there's a lot of fucking shit.
Yeah.
Cause they never come out. Because if the
government can lie about that, they can.
What else can they learn?
Right.
Everything from 1969 is cheaper,
easier and faster to do today except
go to the mode and it's like there's
nothing else that jets are faster.
The weapons are better,
the technology is better
for communication.
Everything's better except space travel
and everybody's will Dutch cause it's a
lot of money. Maybe. Maybe it's
possible that that's all it is.
It's possible that everybody just looks
for a conspiracy and everything and it's
like you're just looking too hard.
And it shows, it seems crazy,
but it's just because there's
an atmosphere list object
and it's out in space.
Maybe. Or maybe they faked
it. That's possible too.
There's a lot of weird shit to it.
There's a lot of weird shit.
But the fact that Neil Armstrong
becomes some sort of a recluse and stops
talking to people and
Buzz Aldrin goes insane.
Fossil Algebra became like a serious
alcoholic after the moon landings.
It's a weird fucking,
there's a lot of weird
something has to get into your
head to make you turn this.
Yeah, there's a lot of weird shit
with the fucking lunar orbiter,
the lunar module he ever,
he ever watched like them try to
do that thing on earth and what,
there's a famous video footage of Neil
Armstrong in that thing and he objects
and it falls to the ground explodes
and blows up in flames. But Dan,
that bitch worked like a charm when
they were up there on the moon though.
They got that off the whole re
engineered and figured out perfectly.
So it worked flawlessly on every mission.
Maybe.
Then there's the prime minister of
Holland was given a moon rock by Neil
Armstrong and buzz Aldrin
and they fucking recently,
like within the last couple of years they
found out that it's not a moon rockets,
petrified wood. This is in a plaque
given to them by the astronauts.
Like here we've brought you back a
souvenir from the moon, sir. Why?
I picked this one myself.
I chipped it off and we brought it to you
because we value the relationship that
America has with your country.
Emails. A piece of petrified wood.
Yeah.
I got duped into buying a watch that,
so I'll let you watch allegedly made from
the face of a moon surface of the Moon
from the moon rock.
Really? I saw one of those,
I saw it was in one of those
super rich guy magazines like a,
it's got Ferrari's on the cover, the
dupont registry, you know, is that,
where'd you got it from? No, I was in a
store that sold high end watches. Tell me,
I'm a watch nerd. So I was like
this company Ro ro Manger Jerome.
How could they possibly get moon rocks?
I don't know that that's going to be
listening. What does it mean? You know,
it's a federal crime to be in possession
of a moon rock. Uh, allegedly.
There was one point in time where they
had auctioned off a piece of moon rock
and they'd just grounded
down to mid company.
This company may took it and made the
inside face of the watch. Oh really?
Just like a little thin layer of it.
And then they made it to shape
like the moon. And then I,
and that same company got a piece
of the titanic was auctioned off
and uh,
they made the Bezel of the watch with a
piece of the iron from the titanic. Wow.
That one's going to believable for me.
That's totally believable. Well, I mean,
I guess they did bring back, no matter
what, even with unmanned spacecrafts,
the Russians brought back a
bunch of moon dust, you know,
not a bunch like enough to make
100,000 fucking watches, but you know,
there's enough to study,
you know, the, um,
the whole subject is such a controversial
subject because it's one of one of the
very few subjects where people immediately
think you are fucking crazy if you
even think about it. Yeah.
And that's a weird thing.
Whenever you get a subject
that's like that, where if you,
if you even consider it, if you don't
even take a stand, if you consider it,
you're a quack and a crazy person, it's
like, I, there are things like that,
like the hollow earth. Yeah,
there are things like that,
but even the hollow earth,
I'll listen to what they have to say.
It sounds completely insane,
but I'll listen to it. When I listened
to my Brian, I just, that hurts him.
What'd you hear?
Sound like a Dork.
Fucking see I in or knocking
or sounds to fucking see NASA.
They're coming, they're coming
for Ya. You know, and it's,
it's one of those things where you use,
a lot of people don't want to talk
about the subject because if you pick a
position or if you do agree that there's
some anomalies and there's some weird
shit to the photography,
the photography,
it looks like they're in spotlights
and you know, there's all,
there's all these discussions about
Pr, you know, intersecting shadows,
shadows coming from different
light sources, that kind of stuff.
I find a little corny,
but it is a little corny,
but the spotlight shit's
not corny. It's like, yeah,
this guy is very clearly
under a light source.
And there's also photos where it looks
like a guy's very clearly filled in.
Like the, the idea the moon is that it's
supposed to be, you know, in, you know,
it's like a zoo, really extreme
contrast. A lot of the photographs of,
of dark and light,
except when there's astronauts involved
when they want a nice clear shot of a
guy coming out of the lunar module.
Meanwhile the sun is behind him.
He should be in darkness.
It's a lot of tricky shit and a lot
of people will come up with excuses.
They'll say, whoa, we could be this,
the contour of the surface of the moon
and reflects like, yes, it could be that.
Or it could be.
There was a dude standing there with a
big fucking piece of aluminum foil and it
was making sure the light fills in that
photograph because they were doing it in
the Goddamn movie studio. That's possible
too, man. When I think area 51 is for,
it's all for developing weapons.
That's what I think.
I think all those things that people
keep seeing in the sky that to Ufo man,
those are easily to be drones.
You know,
that to me is more likely than
aliens wanted us so badly.
They wanted human fetal tissue so
badly that they were willing to give us
fucking flying saucers.
Yeah. Like, come on man.
I don't believe there has been over
11 flying saucers have crashed.
So we have possession of really,
okay. Really Matt Etsy, one crashing.
I could see, I could see a bunch of
crashing over the course of human history,
but I think there'd be some evidence.
I don't think you'd be able to hold that
back. People have stories about shit,
but I don't know if I believe I need to
talk to him about a lot of other shit.
You know,
you start talking to me about Ufos.
I need to know what you
think about ghosts. You know,
I need to sit you down and you know,
do you think that you can read minds?
Do you believe in palm reading what he
bought? What about Tarot cards? You know,
I'm not into that stuff.
Yeah.
But you know what I'm saying when I'm
talking to dude who believes in Ufos,
I need to know if you believe in
chem trails, motherfucker, I need to.
But if you believe in a lot of weird shit,
you know,
are you one of those weird shit,
believe and dude's,
cause there's a lot of people that just
love to believe in crazy shit. They just,
they look forward to be more interesting.
Yes. It's sexy. Aliens are sexy.
So, so hot right now. So Bro,
I mean, isn't it 2012 or sexy?
You know, any, anything crazy and
unknown, bigfoot, sexy, loch ness monster,
sexy killer. Whales aren't sexy
there at fucking seaworld, right?
It's easy to get to there, see them all
the time, but they're just as fascinating.
If you didn't know, you know, the, if
you didn't know that an animal existed,
that's almost as intelligent as a man
that has this incredibly varied language.
Speaks with sound.
It actually breeds a hair,
but it lives in the middle of the ocean
and it kills fish and fucks up sharks.
He'd be like, Whoa, this is real.
That's would be way crazier than a
lot of animals that are mythical.
I can like the loch ness monster was
that fucking pussy do that piece of shit.
I don't even know what that was.
I've never boughten into the button.
I've never bought into the Loch ness
monster tells you ologies a weird field
because there are things
that we have not discovered.
Definitely there's that
fucking gorilla that they've,
or the chimpanzee they've
recently discovered in the
Congo. It's a giant Bondo.
Ape is huge.
Chimpanzee is over the last couple of
decades they've figured out there really
is this giant subspecies of
chimpanzee cause they can't, yeah.
So now it's like six feet tall,
but they can find things.
There's a few things that are out there.
Like in New Guinea,
they found like some crazy fucking
frog and some weird psychedelic looking
animals.
And if they find weird shit and like
rainforests and in places there stuff that
we still probably haven't seen yet.
But there's not a lot, you know,
there's not a lot of stuff. It's
not, it's not like the old days.
Some of the old days when they
discovered gorillas. I'm like,
what the fuck is that? You
know that happened, man.
It was like not that long ago where
they discovered gorillas like,
you gotta be fucking checkmate.
Nobody knew this. Europeans man,
when they went to Africa
for the first time,
do you know how fucking crazy it must
have been the first time they discovered a
gorilla? You know they're
walking into, what else is here,
John Welders and the size of your
hand, Fred, give me the machete.
What's hacked through some,
what the fuck is that?
Just a big giant silver back comes running
at you and they have to shoot it and
then they fucking kill it and put it up
on ropes and shit and carry a big log to
the village and w what the fuck is this?
And they're like,
that is our fantasy cover. That
shit dude. People back then,
that will lived around gorillas.
They weren't writing books.
They're in the right shit.
They didn't even, you know,
they didn't have any paper to do.
They were just had a religion. Oh,
did they? I don't think they even did
the people that live in the Congo,
what kind of religions do they
have in the Congo? I Dunno.
People that like those people that like
you ever see the people that like hang
off of trees and catch fish from the
river with nuts. It's fucking nuts.
Hang upside down. They just hang with
their hands and feet there barefoot.
These people are living like they lived
a hundred thousand years ago and they do
that still to this day.
There's all this video of him too that
people have gone there and even video in
black and white like way back in the
forties and the 50s and these people climb
out on these trees that,
that,
that hang over the Congo over the
river and they're, they're literally,
they fall in your dead man.
You're fucked.
And there's all these people and loved
ones and they're catching fish with nets
and they're just so good at it.
They've been doing it for so long.
It's like they grew up climbing
on these trees, hanging over the,
hanging over this raging fucking
river and scooping fish out of it.
That video you tweeted the other day
where the guy was climbing that tower,
by the way. That was fucking
scary. I hate that shit. Which one?
There's a video or do tribes?
It's like well over a thousand feet.
It's one of those, uh, electrical
towers was, it was a radio tower.
It's like a radio towers.
Yeah, same. Same as that.
The empire state building. Is that what
it was saying? It was the same time.
Something along those lines is insane.
How tall it was.
And this guy was free climbing it.
You know,
the elevator takes you
up to a certain point,
but once you get to a certain point,
then you have to free climb.
And he was free climbing. Fuck, walk
carrying this bag. That's like 30 pounds,
30 pounds. It's tools, tools cause
he's got to fix this fucking thing.
Oh this is a real,
I think it wasn't doing it for fun too,
but there's a whole a part where
he's climbing where he's outside.
There's some part of it. It's the freak
out is he's inside this thing, you know,
inside the structure.
This.
Eventually he gets outside the structure
and he has to climb all the way to the
top because it gets thinner
and thinner and thinner,
so it's just a pole with some things
that stick off the side that you have to
grab a hold of them, handles and
climb. It's such a freak out dude.
You could see 50 miles in
either way from up there.
I had to turn that shit off to to freak
you out. I started freaking myself out.
When it gets to a certain part of
heights, I'm just like, all right, that's,
that's crazy heights or scary as
fuck man heights or scary as fuck.
There's something about it,
man.
It just makes your toes curl and
your butthole clench his shit
and an honesty. If it was the
opposite, like extreme depth,
I'd probably be the same way.
Like if I was like,
you know the same distance like underneath
the water. Did you see that video?
The guy free diving.
There's a video that's online.
Then I'll tweet it later on today.
There's a video of a guy free dive diving.
Any free dive. Some insane
amount, like a hundred meters.
[inaudible] yeah, I guess that's
what we can do. He can do 124 meters.
I was like the most he's ever done.
You know how, how do they engage?
That is watched with a stop. They
hair. I don't know. Got a world.
No, they can hold their breath
for like five minutes, man.
Some of these free divers and
more five minutes, six minutes,
seven minutes underwater. I think
about that shit. Fuck that. Yeah.
Why do you want to do that man?
That's just doesn't seem like a smart
thing to do. All right. People are home.
They're making noise right here,
ladies and gentlemen.
Thank you Mr. Russell Peters.
You're a scholar and a gentleman
and a fantastic standup comedian.
And if people want to get in contact
with you, uh, what is the best way?
The Real Russell pee on Twitter? That is
correct. At the two s's. Two L's correct.
The Real Russell P at Twitter.
And uh, what's your website?
Russell peters.com shall
Sam bitches much love.
Thank you to the fleshlight
for sponsoring this show.
Thank you to Brian Red van
for his technical expertise
and his human roadblocks
skills. Thank you to uh, to everyone,
ladies and gentlemen, to all you.
Freaky bitches. February 4th,
Mandalay Bay theater. Me, Joe Diaz,
Ari Shaffir Superbowl weekend.
Friday night. It's going down.
Get on in. We're going to have
a crazy party. Russell Peters.
What are you doing on
February 4th weekend?
I'll be in Toronto on
February 2nd or third.
Are you going to be in a corporate gig?
You're going to be in Vegas for
the UFC weekend? That weekend? Yes.
If I, uh, if I can be, I will be
if my gigs not on the same night.
Yeah, I can tell you right. Saturday
night. Tell me cause it's the fifth.
The fifth is UFC. The fifth is the UFC
and Russell Peters is a big UFC fan.
Did you see Anthony Pettis
is fucking kick last night.
Did you see what happened last
night? Oh, what am I missing?
You know who Anthony passes?
Showtime Pettis.
He's now the new WEC lightweight champion.
He fought Ben Henderson and there was
a crazy back and forth fight until the
fifth round.
He jumps off the size of the case side
of the cage with his foot kicks off the
cage and flying through the air kicks
Ben Henderson in the face and knocks him
down. It was the nuttiest
shit in my life. No,
no, no. I went to a decision, but
looking at that and fucking kick.
Ben Henderson's a bad motherfucker. It
was a great scrap. Up until that point,
there was a lot of back and forth action.
He had a Henderson's back.
Henderson had his back.
He had Henderson's back standing up.
It was real back and forth for a while
until like the last round man pedis
really came on strong. The last
round was pedis. You know, he, he,
he heard him a couple times with punches,
but even then he, in that last round,
Henderson had Pettis on his back.
It was a really enter any,
I believe you had Pettis is back to,
it was a really interesting fight, man.
It was a wild scrap.
Anthony Pettis is a bad mother fucker,
but the fact that he pulled
that off was just insane.
The fight was a really closely matched
fight. You know, I think pedis.
Who did I definitely one the decision.
Ben Henderson's a bad mother fucker too.
Didn't he fight for cowboys?
Serone no, he's bigger.
He's won 55 Henderson
fought a cowboy Cerrone.
That was a great fight to great fights.
And the last one he caught him with a
Kia guillotine and he's Kinda Taichii and
team. It's got a good submission
game, good standup game, pedis,
just better puncher.
That was one of big things in it.
And Pedis is wilder and you know the,
the pet or pedis had better
success at the ground too.
He was able to hold onto Henderson a
little bit better than Henderson was able
to hold on to him. But it was close. It
was good. It was a fucking, you know,
it was one of those matches
where even though, you know, yes,
the decision was the correct decision.
Like man,
while it was happening was so suspenseful
because both guys were so good and so
much action was going on and both guys
knew that you couldn't fuck up even for a
second. Cause if you did,
you'd get jacked. Like for
one guy would make a mistake,
the other guy would have his back.
You know, one guy made a sec,
the other guy would be on
the top, you know, it was a,
it was a really high paced,
you know,
really exciting fight until that last
kick and that that was the nuttiest shit I
have ever seen in my life is pretty crazy.
It's just a few seconds to go in the
last round per minute to judge kicks.
It's not major extent that
guys, he's a, on another level,
this is the new level.
This is back.
You know when hoists Gracie
was around and you know he,
you angled triangle Dan Severn off his
back and I was like, this is crazy.
He's on another level.
This is the next level.
The next level is dudes are jumping off
the cage and fucking kicking you in.
You've got all these kids that
just studied MMA their whole life.
They didn't study one or the other.
Well,
he actually started out a taekwondo
black belt though. Taekwondo guys.
Just think there's a couple of
the new guy named John Mack.
Jesse to fought in Toronto or in
a Montreal rather. And uh, he's a,
another taekwondo guy.
Two's got these wild ass fucking kicks,
these taekwondo class chances. Well, most
of it sucks. Yeah. Most of it is like,
probably the problem with tag window
is you got to keep your hands down.
Everybody keeps her hands down. That's
what they fight. And it's mostly,
you can only kick to the face.
You can't punch to the face.
So it's a really unrealistic style. I
mean, that's what I started out as like,
that's why I did a long period in my life.
But what's good about that is you've
developed crazy leg dexterity and you
develop the ability to do God's
shit. No, he never tried any kick.
My legs are terrible. You
know, the only, the best,
most effective kicks or tool legs.
Yeah. You know, like more time. Yes.
I decided the knee, if you want to, you
want to take some shit, right? You know,
I'll hook you don't want to go
after we get off line, I'll,
I'll tell you exactly where to go.
We'll hook it up after he tells you
where he lives because you can't know you
fucking dirty freaks. Alright.
That's the end of the show. It Shit.
It had to end eventually and now it does.
I love you bitches. I love everybody.
I love Brian. I love Russell Peters.
I'm glad to have, I'm very fortunate.
Such cool friends. Thank you sir. Thank
you. Oh, let me give you one Brian.
I don't leave you hanging off
and um, uh, thank you everybody.
Thank you for tuning
in and we'll see soon.
I'm healthy. I'm healthy. I'm not
sick anymore. So, uh, that's the,
that's it for this weekend.
We won't have any this weekend,
but we're going to have a bunch of
next week. I got a Lotta people on tap.
Greg Fitzsimmons contacted me. We're
going to do one with Greg Fitzsimmons.
We're going to work in.
Who else? Brian. Uh,
we're going to try and get Brian Passaic,
Brian Post saying I'm going to
work on him and getting glides,
a slashing during the
live session juror and uh,
oh nick Swardson exports up near damn dog.
This a lot.
And I want us to get birth Chrysler
too soon. Get handler. Yes.
We get a lot of people bitches.
We got a lot of shit happen.
Thank you very much for all the love.
We love you back. See Ya. Bye. Bye.
[inaudible].